THIS IS A INFORMATIONAL HEARING
SO -- WE
WILL BE TAKING ACTION ON
ANYTHING JUST HAVING A
DISCUSSION.
OF AND SO AS A RESULT WE DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE A QUORUM A CALL
ROLE BUT I DID WANT TO WAIT TO
AT LEAST ONE OF MY COLLEAGUE
SOME GROUND OVER THE I'LL.
ARRIVE OF DISCUSSIONS THAT OUR
SUBCOMMITTEES TYPICALLY FOCUS ON
PRISONS AND COURTS BUT AS A
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY.
WE ALSO COVER HOW THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
SUPPORT CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
COORDINATING RESOURCES AND
SERVICES IN TIMES OF DISASTER.
IN THE LAST YEAR OUR STATE HAS
INTO UNPRECEDENTED NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT HAVE CAUSED
DEVASTATION TO CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE.
WHILE WE CAN CALCULATE THE LOSS
OF PHYSICAL STRUCTURES THE COST
OF LIVES LOST IS IN IMMEASURABLE.
ONE THIS NEW REALITY IS
SOMETHING THAT AS A STATE WE CAN
BETTER BE PREPARED FOR AND WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. TO ENSURE THAT
EFFICIENT COORDINATION AND
ADEQUATE RESOURCES I FIT
EFFICIENTLY DELIVERED WHEN
DISASTER STRIKES.
TODAY WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOCAL CITY
AND COUNTY.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
HOW THAT COORDINATION HAPPENS
AND OPPORTUNITIES IN THE WHO
RIDE ON THE EYES AND TO IMPROVE
DISASTER RELEASE AND RESPONSE.
I'M NOT SURE IF ANY OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
SOUNDS LIKE A PLAN HOW GREAT
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE A
PANEL IN THE PANELIST ARE HELEN
KIRSTINE WHO IS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OKAY SOMEONE FROM TWO PEOPLE
FROM THE DIRECTOR WHO'S FROM THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNMENT.
OFFICE OF B. EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND YOU'LL GIVE US YOUR NAMES
WHEN YOU START SOUNDS GOOD.
ARRAY RIORDAN IS ALSO HERE WHO
IS THE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS SERVICE ASSOCIATION AND
THE REST OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT.
AND HOLLY HOWARD WHO IS ALSO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
ARE WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
OUR I THINK WITH THE DIRECTORS.
GOING TO SPEAK FIRST I'M SORRY.
OUR LEGISLATIVE ALICE IS GOING
TO SPEAK FIRST AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TELLING CHRISTINE NOT
JUST LAID OF ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
YOU SHOULD HAVE A HAND OUT IN
FRONT OF YOU THAT THE SERGEANTS
PASSED OUT THAT'S ALSO AVAILABLE
ONLINE.
AND THAT WILL --
GUIDE MY REMARKS THIS AFTERNOON
SO I'M GONNA SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT -- YES
HIS ROLE RELATED TO DISASTERS
EMERGENCIES I MEAN AT FIRST JUST
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE THEIR ROLE I'M
NOT GONNA GO INTO A LOT OF
DETAIL BECAUSE THEY ARE HERE TO
PROVIDE.
MORE OF AN IN DEPTH.
DESCRIPTION OF THEIR ROLE AS
WELL AS I'M SOME DISCUSSION OF
THAT THEIR ROLE SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO THE RECENT DISASTERS --
BUT I'M JUST GONNA BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZE THAT AND THEN I'M
GONNA TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
RECENT BUDGET ACTIONS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TAKEN --%
RELATED TO DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCY --
ITEMS -- FOR
YES ITS BUDGET AS WELL AS SOME
OF COVER SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT WILL BE IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. FOR THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET --
AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE
DISCUSSING THOSE FURTHER AT AN
UPCOMING HEARING BUT I'M JUST
GOING TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THOSE
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE.
ONE WE COVER THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
DISASTERS AND WE REALLY DIVIDE
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES INTO FOUR
MAIN AREAS --
IN THIS HANDOUT YOU CAN KIND OF
SLICE AND DICE THEM DIFFERENT
WAYS BUT REALLY HOWEVER YOU LOOK
AT IT THEY'RE INVOLVED IN
DISASTERS SORT OF FROM BEGINNING
TO END ACTUALLY EVEN BEFORE
DISASTER STARTS TO WELL AFTER
THE DISASTER OCCURS.
SO THE FIRST THING THAT THEY'RE
INVOLVED IN WAS RELATED TO
PLANNING.
A SO THEY PREPARE VARIOUS STATE
PLANS RELATED TO DISASTERS
INCLUDING THE STATE'S HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN WHICH IDENTIFIES
SOME OF THEM MADE.
HAZARD WE HAVE THE STATE LIKE
EARTHQUAKES WILDFIRES AND FLOODS
WERE WE HAVE UNFORTUNATELY A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT --
HAZARDS IN THE STATE AS WELL AS
WAYS TO MITIGATE THOSE.
THEY ALSO PREPARE THE STATE'S
DISASTER PLAN AND THEY ALSO
SUPPORT LOCAL ENTITIES AS WELL
AS OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND THE
PREPARATION OF THEIR PLANNING
ACTIVITIES.
THE SECOND MAJOR FUNCTION THAT
WE COVER HERE IS COMMUNICATIONS
SO THE DEPARTMENT DOES A NUMBER
OF THINGS RELATED TO
COMMUNICATIONS THEY FACILITATE
EMERGENCY WARNINGS.
THEY ALSO --
SUPPORT PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS I'M GONNA
CALL IT JUST A FEW OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY DO THE ACTUAL DUE A
NUMBER OF THINGS IN THIS AREA --
BUT A FEW OF THE THINGS THAT
WILL COME BACK TO LATER IN THE
HAND OUT INCLUDING.
AYE SUPPORTING THE EARTHQUAKE
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM IT IS A
SYSTEM THAT'S UNDER DEVELOPMENT
AND IS DESIGNED TO GIVE PEOPLE
ADVANCE WARNING OF AN UPCOMING
EARTHQUAKE.
ID ALSO.
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THE STATE'S
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM SO FOLKS CAN
CALL IN IN THE EVENT OF A
DISASTER AND SEEK ASSISTANCE
FROM REGENCY RESPONDERS.
AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO
SYSTEM WHICH ALLOWS FIRST
RESPONDERS TO CONTACT EACH OTHER
AND COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER
I'M IN TIMES OF A DISASTER AS
WELL AS OTHER EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS.
THE THIRD MAIN FUNCTION THAT
THEY PERFORM IS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY AND THEY REALLY
MONITORING COORDINATE THE
RESPONSE RECOVERY EFFORTS OF THE
STATE.
AND THAT INCLUDES FOR EXAMPLE
TASKING OTHER DEPARTMENTS --
WITH RESPONDING SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF WE NEED TECH COLLINS
MEDICINAL SUPPORT FROM THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
ALSO HEARD IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
THEY WOULD BE THE ONE WHO
ATTACKED THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT
WITH COMING IN PROVIDING THAT
ASSISTANCE.
THEY ALSO COORDINATE THE STATE'S
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AND THIS IS A
SYSTEM OF NEIGHBOR HELPING
NEIGHBOR WHERE ONE COMMUNITY IF
THEY'RE OVERWHELMS I'M CAN GET
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS EITHER WITHIN THE
STATE OR IN SOME CASES IN THE
EVENT OF A VERY MAJOR DISASTER
SOMETIMES EVEN OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE -- I
ALSO WANTED TO JUST POINT OUT IN
THIS AREA THAT THEY HAVE SOME
FIRE ENGINES THAT OUR STATE ON
FIRE ENGINES THAT ARE PROVIDED
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
OFFER USING MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
WILL COME BACK TO THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN --
PROVIDED IN PAST YEARS AND SO
THEY FACILITATE.
THE PROVISION OF THOSE ENGINES
AND AND THE COORDINATION OF
THOSE ENGINES AS WELL.
AND THEN THE FOURTH MAJOR
ACTIVITY IS THE ADMINISTRATION
OF DISASTER ASSISTANCE FUNDING --
BASTER IS BASICALLY THE CONDUIT
FOR STATE ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE --
AND THEIR COUPLE KEY KINDS OF
ASSISTANCE I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
HERE IN TERMS OF STATE
ASSISTANCE. ONE OF THE MAJOR --
AREAS A STATE ASSISTANCE IS THE
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT AND THIS IS A FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDED TO HELP PREPARE A
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S
PROVIDED TO HELP LOCALS FOR
EXAMPLE -- A
COVER SOME OF THE COSTS RELATED
TO DISASTER RESPONSE AS WELL --
AGAIN WILL COME BACK TO THIS WE
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS --
AND THEN IN TERMS OF FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING TO KEEP IN MIND
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD TO VERY
LARGE DISASTERS.
SO WHEN THE STATE EXPERIENCES
DISASTERS OF THE SCALE WITH
EXPERIENCE UNFORTUNATELY A
NUMBER OF TIMES IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WE CAN SOMETIMES
GET WHAT'S CALLED A MAJOR
DISASTER DECLARATION.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS IT MAKES
AVAILABLE A VARIETY OF TYPES OF
FEDERAL FUNDING INCLUDING FOR
THINGS LIKE FIRE RESPONSE DEBRIS
REMOVAL --
ALSO IT HELPS.
I STILL WITH OTHER THINGS LIKE
REBUILDING PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND THEN THERE'S ANOTHER FEDERAL
PROGRAM THAT IT MAKES AVAILABLE
WHICH I'M GONNA ALSO COME BACK
TO LATER BUT I WANT TO JUST
MENTION IT QUICKLY HERE.
IT'S CALLED THE DISASTER THE
HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM.
AND THIS PROGRAM IS AT EIGHT
BECAUSE BASICALLY WHAT IT DOES
IT IS WITH THE STATE HAS
EXPERIENCED VERY SIGNIFICANT
DISASTERS IT PROVIDES FUNDING TO
HELP US MITIGATE FUTURE
DISASTERS.
SO UP 220% OF THE FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE WE GET FOR SHIP
RESPONDING TO REBUILDING FROM
THE DISASTER WE CAN GET --
IN THE FORM OF ASSISTANCE TO
HELP US.
REALLY BE MORE RESILIENT TO
FUTURE DISASTERS.
SO JUST ONE THING TO KEEP IN
MIND IS TYPICALLY WITH FEDERAL
GADIS FEDERAL DISASTER FUNDS IF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COVERS
ABOUT 75% OF THE COST USUALLY
THE STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COVER THE REMAINING 25% ALTHOUGH
THAT CAN VARY.
DEPENDING ON A VARIETY OF
FACTORS.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO WE
SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE RECENT
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS RECEIVED THE LAST
FEW YEARS THIS DOESN'T INCLUDE.
THE FUNDING IT'S BEEN PROVIDED
THROUGH --
AS CURRENT YOUR ADJUSTMENTS
THROUGH WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE
DISASTER RESPONSE IN ECONOMIC --
OR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT
EXCUSE ME --
THIS IS JUST THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH A FOR EXAMPLE THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE.
BUT THIS SUMMARIZES SUMMER IT
SUMMARIZES THOSE AUGMENTATIONS
AND THERE'S A LOT GOING IN ON IN
THIS CHART I'M NOT GONNA GO
THROUGH EVERY ITEM BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S DEFINITELY A LOT BUT I WANT.
TO POINT OUT A FEW THEMES THAT
YOU SEE HERE THINGS THAT WE'VE
FUNDED A COUPLE OF TIMES IN
RECENT YEARS ONE IS CDA ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT -- WHICH
I MENTIONED BEFORE WE PROVIDED
BUT ONE TIME AND SOME ON GOING
AUGMENTATIONS RELATED TO CD A IN
RECENT YEARS IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AS
WELL AS EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ANOTHER MAJOR THEME IS FIRE
ENGINES --
AND ALL AGAIN MULTIPLE TIMES IN
RECENT YEARS AND IN ALL THESE
YEARS ACTUALLY PROVIDED SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING EITHER --
FOR BUYING ADDITIONAL ENGINES OR
AND OR FOR PRE POSITIONING
MUTUAL AID ENGINES SO ACTUALLY
IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AS PART OF
THE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT.
PROPOSAL THAT WAS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ENGINES ON A NISSAN
MANY FOR PRE POSITIONING AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AS WELL AS
MANY IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR
BOTH.
OB PURCHASING ADDITIONAL ENGINES
AS WELL AS PRE POSITIONING.
AT ANOTHER MAJOR THEME YOU'LL
SEE A MULTIPLE YEARS OF FUNDING
FOR THE EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM MOST OF THAT WAS PROVIDED
ON A ONE TIME BASIS TO BUILD OUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THAT
SYSTEM --
AND THEN THERE'S SOME OTHER
COMMUNICATIONS RELATED PROPOSALS
THAT YOU'LL OR THAT WERE PRE OF
THAT YOU'LL SEE HERE.
I WON I WON A COTTON
SPECIFICALLY IS THE NINE ONE ONE
SUSTAINMENT PROGRAM --
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WAS
CONSIDERED BY THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR AND APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND THAT FINDS AN UPGRADE OF THE
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEMS WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE NEXT GEN NINE ONE
SYSTEM.
OUT OF A SPECIAL FUNDS --
AND THERE'S SOME STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCES BATTLE BUT ON THE
NEXT PAGE.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE WE
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PACKAGE THE FIRST TO I'M
NOT GONNA GO INTO MUCH DETAIL
THOSE WERE BOTH INCLUDED AS PART
OF AB SEVENTY TWO WHICH IS
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON THERE IS SOME MONEY FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION AS WELL AS A
GENERAL FUND LOAN IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO SUPPORT THE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM --
AND THEN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS --
WHICH WILL BE CONSIDERED BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE --
AT AN UPCOMING HEARING I BELIEVE
I'VE JUST BRIEFLY GOING TO
SUMMARIZE SOME OF THOSE --
THERE SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
ONGOING INCREASE THE FEDERAL
TRUST FUND AT THE ALREADY.
I RELATED TO THAT HAZARD
MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM THAT I
MENTIONED SO THIS THE STATE IS --
EXPECTING TO RECEIVE A BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THIS PROGRAM.
SO THAT COULD BE A BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE CAN INVEST IN
OUR COMMUNITIES TO HELP THEM BE
MORE RESILIENT TO POTENTIAL
DISASTERS WHETHER IT BE
HARDENING BUILDINGS FOR
EARTHQUAKES IN MAKING THE MORE --
STRENGTH STRONGER FOR
EARTHQUAKES OR CREATING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE FOR FIRES ON
ALL THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FUNDING SO
THERE COULD BE A BILLION DOLLARS
AND THE DEPARTMENT IS --
WORKING TOWARDS --
PROVIDING GRANTS FOR THAT
FUNDING GRANTS.
AT THE SECOND BULLET HERE IS
RELATED TO THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM THERE ACTUALLY TWO
SEPARATE PROPOSALS HERE WHAT IS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO SET NAPA --
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT
UPGRADED TO THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM AS WELL AS JUST SUPPORT
THE EXISTING SYSTEM.
ON BECAUSE OF THAT FUND
CONDITION ISSUE I MENTIONED
THERE'S ALSO A SEPARATE PROPOSAL
FOR ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT WHAT'S CALLED IS WHAT'S
CALLED FIRST NAT.
ON WHICH IS CONSERVE A BACKBONE
BROADBAND --
TECHNOLOGY TO SUPPORT THE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM.
THERE'S ALSO TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING AND THAT WOULD
ON AN ONGOING BASIS SUPPORT THE
PRE POSITIONING OF THOSE ENGINES
SO WE'VE FUNDED ON A ONE TIME
BASIS IN PAST YEARS IN THIS
WOULD BE ON GOING FUNDING.
THERE'S ALSO A PROPOSAL FOR ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR CDA --
SO WE'VE PROVIDED SO AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE SOME PAST
FUNDING IN THIS WOULD BE I AM%
ANOTHER YEAR FUNDING FOR THAT
FUNDING AUGMENTATION FOR THAT.
PROBABLY REFLECTS JUST THAT THE
GROWING AMOUNT OF DISASTERS
WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS.
THERE'S ALSO --
SOMEONE TIME FINDING SIXTEEN
MILLION PROPOSED FOR THE
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING SYSTEM
THAT WILL BASICALLY COMPLETE THE
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OTHER SAID ONE TIME COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SYSTEM --
AND NOT NEED TO BE AN ONGOING
FUNDING SO FINDING SOLUTION
DEVELOPED FOR THAT SYSTEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA BE ON
GOING COST --
THAT WILL ALSO COME ABOUT IS
PART OF THAT SYSTEM.
AND IN THE LAST --
I ITEM I WANNA HIGHLIGHTED THE
PUBLIC SAFETY RADIOS THERE'S A
MULTI YEAR FUNDING PROPOSAL
RELATED TO PUBLIC SAFETY RADIOS --
AND REALLY OPERATING THAT SYSTEM
TO ME IT'LL AND ADD MORE
FUNCTIONALITY TO THAT SYSTEM.
SO THOSE ARE REALLY THE KEY
BUDGET ITEMS OF NOTE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS --
MAYBE EITHER BEFORE OR AFTER WE
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT MUCH OF
A REAL QUICK ONE IF I COULD GET.
YOU SAID THAT OF A BILLION
DOLLARS.
WAS COMING. TO HELP MITIGATE
THESE --
PROPOSALS.
BUT I DON'T SEE WHAT.
DID I MISUNDERSTAND THAT WEARS
YEAH INCOME FROM SO THERE'S A
BILL THERE'S WE'RE EXPECTING
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS YOU'RE
NOT GONNA SEE THAT REFLECTED IN
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THERE'S
A COUPLE REASONS WHY.
ONE THE DEPARTMENT HAS A BASE
BUDGET AMOUNT TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDS AND SO AND THAT'S QUITE
SUBSTANTIAL SO THEY CAN ALREADY
RECEIVED QUITE A BIT OF FEDERAL
FUNDS WITHOUT A BUDGET
AUGMENTATION.
AND THEN ALSO THE SIXTY MILLION
IS -- AN
ONGOING FUNDING --
INCREASE AND SO ACTUALLY THEY'RE
EXPECTING TO RECEIVE THAT
FEDERAL FUNDING --
FIND INCREASE OVER SEVERAL YEARS
AND SO THEY ARE PROPOSING TO
SIXTY MILLION TO ALLOW THEM TO
RECEIVE IT OVER SEVERAL YEARS SO
ULTIMATELY WE EXPECT TO RECEIVE
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS BUT
WE'RE NOT SEEING THAT ALL IS A
BUDGET INCREASE THIS YEAR.
ON BUT IS STILL SOMETHING THAT
LEGISLATURE WILL BE MADE VERY
SOON -- AND
THEIR DIFFERENT TIMELINES FOR
THE SPECIFIC ONES BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ONE OF WANNA BE KEEPING AN EYE
ON NOT BECAUSE IT IS A LOT OF
MONEY FOR THAT TYPE OF PROGRAM.
IN THE BECOMING FOR THE FIT YES
THIS IS FEDERAL FUNDING NOT
STATE FUNDING.
YEAH BECAUSE YOU HAVE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE MILLION AND THEN
THIRTY MILLION OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT.
THAT'S NOT IT QUITE CLOSE TO A
BILLION YEAH NO SORRY THE
BILLION --
IT'S JUST THAT'S REALLY JUST
RELATED TO THAT FEDERAL TRUST
THE FIRST BULLET THERE UNDER
THAT ONE TWENTY THREE THAT
FEDERAL TRUST FUND AUTHORITY --
INCREASE OF THE SIXTY MILLION SO
BASICALLY SIXTY MILLION IT'S OFF
ON GROWING FUNDING BUT THAT'S ON
TOP OF THE BASE FEDERAL FUNDS
AUTHORITY THAT THEY HAVE --
WHICH IS QUITE SIGNIFICANT AND I
THINK IT'S MAYBE AROUND SIX
HUNDRED MILLION SO THEY HAVE
QUITE A BIT OF FEDERAL FUNDS AT
FORTY IN WITH THIS AUGMENTATION
THEY'RE ANTICIPATING BEING ABLE
TO ACCEPT THE FULL AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT DAY.
ANTICIPATE RECEIVING MY
UNDERSTANDING THANK YOU CAN QUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WEBER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE MY NAME IS
GRACE COKE I AM THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THE DIRECTOR OF MARKET OUR DUTY
SENDS HIS APOLOGIES FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY BUT I AM PRIVILEGED --
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
AND PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
OUR PROGRAMS.
HELEN DID A GREAT JOB IN LAYING
A BASE DEPUTY DIRECTOR MOREAU
OVER RECOVERY WHO BUT MORE ABOUT
THE RESPONSE EVERY OPERATIONS WE
HAVE AN AND IN THE AYE OUR NEW
CHIEF YOU ROLL.
AND CHIEF MARK PAYS AND FROM OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT
COME UP PARTS OF OUR DISCUSSION
TODAY.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO TWO
DOCUMENTS YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU -- ONE
OF THEM IS OUR STRATEGIC PLAN'S
SUMMARY WHICH IS IN THE PROCESS
OF BEING UPDATED.
AND FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE
DISCUSSION IF YOU GO TO THE
CENTER FOLDER THAT DOCUMENT --
I'LL JUST BUCKET THE
DESCRIPTIONS AND OVERVIEWS IN AT
IN LINE WITH THAT.
AND THEN --
BEHIND YOU AND PERHAPS IN FRONT
OF YOU YOU HAVE A DOCUMENT THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN BEFORE IT'S
SUCH JUST KIND OF HOUSE SOME OF
OUR EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
CAPABILITIES ARE ORGANIZED.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HOMELAND
SECURITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS.
SO BRIEFLY.
OUR MISSION IS TO PROTECT
PROPERTY LIVES AND PROPERTY
BUILD CAPABILITIES AND SUPPORT
OUR COMMUNITIES FOR RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA WE DO THAT THROUGH A
VARIETY OF OF INTER GOVERNMENTAL.
COOPERATIVE RELATIONS WITH ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND NONPROFITS IN ALL
PHASES OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
IN THE CORNER YOU HAVE
MITIGATION OF PREPAREDNESS
RECOVERING RESPONSES SO IT'S
KIND OF THE CONTINUE ON OF
NONSTOP PLANNING PREPAREDNESS
RESPONDING AND RECOVERING --
SO BASICALLY --
STATE WORK COUNCIL IN NINETEEN
FORTY THREE WE BECAME THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY IN TWO THOUSAND
FOR A WE MERGED WITH THE OFFICE
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE PLANNING
WHICH IS WHERE AND WHEN WE GOT A
LOT OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROGRAMS VICTIM SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PROGRAMS.
THAN A TWO THOUSAND NINE WE
MERGE WITH THE OFFICE OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WHICH THEN
ALLOWS THE DIRECTOR TO NOT ONLY
BE THE EMERGENCY SERVICES
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT DIRECTOR
BUT ALSO THE HOMELAND SECURITY
OFFICE AND THE ADVISER.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WE MERGE WITH
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS WHICH IS A VERY
LARGE GROUP I THINK HELLO
OUTLINED A LOT OF THOSE PROGRAMS
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT THOSE AND
IN SHORT ORDER.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED PERMANENT FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES AND WE'VE HIRED
HUNDREDS OF OTHER TEMPORARY HELP
TO HELP US MEET THE NEED OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS OF DISASTERS --
SO IN OUR PLANNING AND
PREPAREDNESS DIRECTOR WHICH IS
IN THE BLUE SECTION OF THE OF
THE ORG CHART.
THAT --
DIRECTORATE HAS STAFF AND
RESOURCES WITH TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE IN REGARD TO EMERGENCY
PLANNING.
UP ALSO THEY MAINTAIN OUR
SYSTEMS OF EMERGENCY PLANNING
AND HOW WE RESPOND INCLUDING THE
STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WE'LL HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT LATER
TODAY.
THEY ALSO MANAGE VERY TECHNICAL
PROGRAM SO LAKE EARLY.
THE EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
PROGRAM --
ALL OF OUR CATASTROPHIC DISASTER
PLANNING OUR DAM EMERGENCY
ACTION PLANS.
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANNING AND A
VERY RICH ROBUST AND
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING PROGRAM
WHO ANNUALLY TRAINS ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND FIRST RESPONDERS
EMERGENCY MANAGERS.
AND OTHER PROFESSIONALS IN A
VARIETY OF ALL HAZARD --
A TRAINING COURSES AND AS WELL
AS CREDENTIALING.
IN OUR RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
DIRECTORATE WE THEY'VE BEEN VERY
BUSY AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM ERIC.
BUT THAT ENCOMPASSES OUR
REGIONAL WE HAVE THREE
ADMINISTRATIVE REGIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
WE ALSO THAT ALSO ENCOMPASSES
OUR FIRE AND RESCUE AND OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HOMELAND
SECURITY AS WELL AS OUR TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN WARNING CENTER.
AND THAT HOUSES OUR TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE AS FAR AS SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS TOOLS DIFFERENT TYPES
OF OF THAT TECHNOLOGY TO
MAINTAIN AN ACCURATE DEPICTION
OF WHAT'S GOING ON A DURING AND
AFTER A DISASTER SO THE KEY THE
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS AND OUR
OFFICES WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WORK WITH THEM ON PLANNING
EXERCISES --
REVIEWING THEIR PLANS BUT ALSO
IN DURING RESPONSE SO THEY WORK
TOGETHER TO RESPOND --
TO TO DISASTERS WITH THEM AS
WELL AS THROUGHOUT THE RECOVERY.
AS HELEN MENTIONED ARE FIRE AND
RESCUE MANAGES THE STATE FIRE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AS WELL AS
MAINTAIN AS EXTENSIVE PROGRAMS
FOR STATE OWNED EQUIPMENT --
FIREFIGHTING CAPABILITIES WITH
WATER RESCUE URBAN SEARCH AND
RESCUE IN A LOT OF A LOT OF
OTHER FIRST RESPONDER ABOUT
PROGRAMS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND HOMELAND
SECURITY MANAGES THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE OF MUTUAL AID
AS WELL AS OTHER.
MASS PLANNING ACTIVITIES THAT
INVOLVE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
SUCH AS CORNERS MUTUAL AID --
LARGE SADIE LARGE STADIUM
SPECIAL EVENT PLANNING AND
TRANSIT SECURITY.
THEY ALSO --
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO THREAT AND
RISK VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS.
IN A RECOVERY SECTION WHICH IS --
HAS GROWN RAPIDLY OVER THE LAST
ACTION THAT OVERS A LOT OF
THOSE CALIFORNIA DISASTER
ASSISTANCE ACT PROGRAMS THAT
HELEN SPOKE.
TO AS WELL AS THE MITIGATION
GRANT PROGRAM AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE ONE CLARIFICATION ON THAT
BILLION DOLLAR SOME OF THE
NUMBERS --
HAVE GONE DOWN SO WE'RE LOOKING
ANYWHERE FROM EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION IT'S DEPENDENT UPON THAT
NUMBER IS DEPENDENT UPON THE
TOTAL COST OF THE DISASTER FOR
ELIGIBLE COSTS WHICH IS --
INFLUX SO JUST WANTED TO TO
MENTION THAT IT THAT MIGHT BE
CLOSER TO EIGHT HUNDRED BUT IT
IS A MOVING TARGET AND THE WAY
YOU DESCRIBE IT WAS ACCURATE IT
IS OVERTIME.
AND HAS TO MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS.
IN LOGISTICS MANAGEMENT --
IN THAT SECTION THEY NOT ONLY
PROVIDE OUR DAY TO DAY
FACILITIES AND CAPITAL OUTLAY
SUPPORT.
THEY ALSO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
LOGISTICS FOR STAGING OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE RESOURCES
WATERSHED PROTECTION --
STAGING IN BASE CAMP OPERATIONS
AS THAT IS WHERE OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATION WHICH IS IN
THE RED SECTION OF OUR OF OUR
HAND OUT OF THE THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER FOR
THE NEXT CHEN.
NINE ONE ONE ALL OF THE NINE ONE
ONE PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINTS.
MANAGING THE STATE EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE.
NUMBER ACCOUNT OR THAT SPECIAL
FUNDING.
AS WELL AS THE FIRST RESPOND OR
NETWORK A THAT'S FIRST
[inaudible]
THEY ALSO LEADERSHIP ROLE WITH
OUR OF OUR STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS IN REGARD TO STATEWIDE
INTER OPERABILITY COORDINATION.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE ALL ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE EFFECTIVELY WHEN
CALLED TO A DISASTER --
AND THEY BASICALLY MAINTAIN OVER
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY PHYSICAL SITES
AND THREE HUNDRED MICROWAVE
PATHS AT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRST
RESPONDERS --
AND UTILITIES CAN ALL
COMMUNICATE --
WHEN NEEDED DURING AN EVENT?
OUR FINAL AHEAD DIRECTOR IT IS
THE FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
AND THAT IS THE AREA THAT
HANDLES YOUR TYPICAL ADMIT ALL
OFFICES BUT ALSO --
THOSE PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
HOMELAND SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROGRAMS VICTIM
SERVICES EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO OVERALL ABOUT TWO BILLION IN
FEDERAL GRANTS --
YOU KNOW GRANTS TO A LOT OF THE
NON PROFITS TO SUPPORT SOME
VITAL VICTIM SERVICES PROGRAMS.
WE ALSO HAVE THREE VERY SPECIAL
OFFICES THAT SERVER CRITICAL
ROLE IN ALL OF OUR DIRECTORATES
AND THAT IS ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS.
OF THAT FOCUS ON DISABILITY
INTEGRATION AND INCLUSION.
ARE PRIVATE SECTOR NGO WHO
FOCUSES IN ON INCORPORATING ALL
OF OUR BUSINESS SECTOR --
PARTNERS INTO OUR PLANNING AND
OUR RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
EFFORTS.
AS WELL THOSE ARE TRIBAL OFFICE
TO INTEGRATE WITH ALL OF THE
HUNDRED NINE FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND OTHERS.
AS WELL AS A MILITARY LIAISON --
WHEN WE EMBARK UPON THE --
SUPPORT FOR THE MILITARY.
SO THAT IS KIND OF AN OVERVIEW
NOT WANTING TO DUPLICATE ANY OF
OF WHAT HELEN SAID BUT ALL I'D
LIKE TO IN THE SEARCH ANY
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO HAVE DIFFERENT WHATEVER
I JUST HAVE A QUESTION.
SIR.
WHAT I'M LOOKING AT THE SUN?
BREAK DOWN HERE AT THE VERY VERY
TOP YOU HAVE DIRECTOR GOVERNOR'S
HOMELAND SECURITY ADVISER YES
DOES THAT INDICATE.
THAT THERE'S SOME KIND OF
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT A MINISTER SOME
FEDERAL AUTHORITY IN THAT.
IS IT ALL STATE IT'S A WELL IT'S
A FEDERAL DESIGNATION THAT
ALLOWS EVERY STATE HAS A OF THE
DESIGNATED HOMELAND SECURITY
ADVISER SO OUR DIRECTOR SERVICES%
THAT ROLE SO IT'S A DUAL ROLE.
SO THERE IS THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF COORDINATION WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BOTH ON HOW MUCH
SECURITY AS WELL AS EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
EQUALLY CONFUSING IS THAT YOU
HAVE AT THE VERY TOP AND YOU
HAVE AN OVER UNDER.
THE RESPONSE SECTION.
AND YOU HAVE THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOMELAND SECURITY WAY DOWN THERE
AS WELL.
SO I'M CONFUSED BY THAT YET --
SO A MEMBER LACKEY I WAS GONNA.
GET INTO EXPLAINING A LITTLE
GREATER DETAIL FOR YOU HOW ARE
THE HOMELAND SECURITY
RESPONSIBILITY WITHIN A RESPONSE
RECOVERY DIRECTOR IT WORKS.
THE DIRECTOR SERVES AT EVERY
STATE AS IT HAS A HOMELAND
SECURITY ADVISER OUR HOMELAND
SECURITY FUNCTIONS WHICH INCLUDE
OUR STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT
CENTER -- IN
OUR STATE PRESIDENT SYSTEM ARE
OVERSEEN BY CHEAP PAYS AND WHO'S
HERE IN THE ROOM WITH US TODAY
HE OVERSEES THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS AND ACTIVITIES OF THE
HOMELAND SECURITY FUNCTIONAL
FEDERAL AUTHORITY.
WELL WE HAVE FEDERAL WE HAVE THE
FORTY TO OVERSEE GRANT DOLLARS
THAT COME IN FOR BOTH A HOMELAND
SECURITY FUNCTIONS AS WELL AS A
MULTITUDE OF OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
COULD NOT JURISDICTIONAL
AUTHORITY.
WHAT WE WE COORDINATE WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS SO --
THERE'S INFORMATION WHICH OVER
AND CLEAR TO ME THAT WILL WORK
ON OUR THESE AND MAYBE IT MAYBE
THE QUESTION IS ARE.
WE ARE DIRECTOR OVER HERE IS
THIS THE SAME PERSON IS DOWN AND
IN THE OF THE SECTION THAT TO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE WHAT YES THE
DOOR GO AHEAD.
THIS OTHERS THE DIRECTOR WHO'S
THE STATE'S HOMELAND SECURITY
ADVISER AND THEN SHE PAYS IN WHO
OVERSEES OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH AND OUR HOMELAND SECURITY
FUNCTION.
AND THE PRIMARY FUNCTION OF THAT
HOMELAND SECURITY GROUP IS THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION AND
INTELLIGENCE FROM LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL SOURCES THERE ARE
FUSION CENTER OPERATIONS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT TO THE DIFFERENT
INFECTIOUS THANK YOU.
SO THE MORNING SO THAT TAKE TO
INDICATE ON THIS SAID THAT CHART
BEHIND YOU IN IN FRONT OF YOU --
THE THIRD OF THE THREE PRIMARY
FUNCTIONS OF YES BEING --
HOMELAND SECURITY CALLOW YES
ACTS AS THE DIRECTOR AXES THE
GOVERNOR'S HOMELAND SECURITY --
ADVISER --
THIS HELLO YES SERVES AS THE
HOME CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT SYSTEM
SAFEGUARDS THE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
BY SERVING AS A DYNAMIC SECURITY
NEXUS BETWEEN THE STATE'S
PRIMARY FUSION CENTER IN THE FOR
REGIONAL.
AND ONE MAJOR URBAN AREA FUSION
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE BRED ASSESSMENT CENTER
THE STACKS OUR PRIMARY FUSION
CENTER IS LOCATED AT CALLOW YES
IT SERVES.
AS AN INFORMATION CLEARINGHOUSE
OF STRATEGIC THREAT ANALYSIS AND
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS REPORTING.
AND ALSO PROVIDES A STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP ACROSS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNITY.
THE STACKS SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO
PREVENT AND PREPARE FOR AND ALSO
MITIGATE AND RESPOND TO ALL
CRIMES AND ALL HAZARDS THAT
AFFECT CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS.
AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THERE'S A VERY COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT UNDER WAY THROUGH THE
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT CENTER
THAT HAS A MULTITUDE.
OF OTHER STATE AGENCY PARTNERS --
OUR CHIEF IRAQ'S DIRECTLY WITH
THE SPECIAL AGENTS IN CHARGE OF
MULTIPLE --
FBI OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AS WELL AS COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION THROUGH OUR REGIONAL
FUSION CENTERS WITH OUR REGIONAL
AND FEDERAL PARTNERS.
IN ADDITION AT THE CAL STAR AT
THE STACK.
WE HAVE COLOCATED THE SITE
CALIFORNIA SIDE STACKED IN
COORDINATES INFORMATION ANALYSIS
AND SHARING WITH A VARIETY OF
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THREAT DETECTION
PREVENTION.
REMEDIATION RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY STRATEGIES IT'S ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPMENT AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY STRATEGY.
THE FOUR CORE PARTNERS IN THE
CAL SEEK OUR KAHLO YES THE STATE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IN THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
I'D LIKE NOW --
AS WE'VE SORT OF LAID OT THE
THE PRIMARY FUNCTIONS OF YES
TALK -- IN A
LITTLE GREATER DETAIL ABOUT THE
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY ACTIVITIES.
THAT WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT BEFORE WE GO
THERE JUST TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT IF YOU LOOK AT THE TIME
THAT --
DIRECTOR KILLER DUDE SHE HAS
SERVED AS DIRECTOR --
IT'S BEEN A REMARKABLE SIX YEARS
OF OF UNFORTUNATE ACTIVITIES
ACROSS THE STATE --
INCLUDING THE DROUGHT --
WHICH WAS A SIGNIFICANT.
IMPACT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN THE GREATEST
IMPACTS WERE SEEN AT AT ANY ONE
TIME WE HAD.
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS --
WHO'D LOST.
A WATER SUPPLIES FROM THEIR
MUNICIPAL FROM BOTH MUNICIPAL
AND PRIVATE WELLS --
WE ALSO IN THIS TIME EXPERIENCE
THE NAPA EARTHQUAKE THAT REFUGIO
OIL SPILL A SIGNIFICANT RESPONSE
ACTIVITY ACROSS MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES.
ALONG THE CENTRAL COAST WE HELP
TO OVERSEE THE RESPONSE --
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO THE
EARLY CO CANYON NATURAL GAS LEAK.
THE SAMBAR TO DENOTE TERRORIST
INCIDENT WAS SOMETHING THAT
CHIEF PAYS AND THEN OUR HOMELAND
SECURITY --
BRANCH WITH IN OUR RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY DIRECTOR IT WAS.
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN SUPPORTING
THE RESPONSE.
TO WE'VE ALSO EXPERIENCE NEARLY
A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
TREES LOST AS A RESULT OF THE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS AS PART OF
THE TREE MORTALITY PROGRAM.
THAT WE SUPPORT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT CAL FIRE.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN DEALING WITH A
NUMBER OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
SOME RECOGNIZED FOR THE PUBLIC
SOME NOT THIS INCLUDES THAT
HAPPENS APPETITE IS C. OUTBREAK.
ZECA VIRUS --
AND A BULLET THREAT AND WE'RE
STILL CURRENTLY DEALING WITH ANY
BREAK IN POULTRY FLOCKS
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE FLOODS OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WERE WERE TREMENDOUS WITH FIFTY
FOUR OF FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
IMPACTED DURING THAT EVENT.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FLOOD
EMERGENCIES ALSO SAW --
THE EMERGENCY AT THE ORVILLE
WHICH RESULTED IN THE LARGEST
NON HURRICANE EVACUATION IN US
HISTORY.
WE WE WENT FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
INTO TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND ON
JANUARY NINTH OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
EXPERIENCED THE DEVASTATING
MONOSYLLABIC SLIDES IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY.
THROUGHOUT TWENTY EIGHTEEN MANY
OF THE THE STATE'S LARGEST AND
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES OR
EXPERIENCE WE HAD TEN OF THE TOP
TWENTY MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY IN. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SIX OF THE TOP TWENTY
LARGEST FIRES.
AND OF COURSE THE DEADLIEST
BEING THE CAMPFIRE AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER HELLO YES HEADQUARTERS
WHERE WE IT THAT IS THE HUB OF
COORDINATION OF ALL STATE
AGENCIES.
RESPONSE IN SUPPORT OF
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY DISASTER.
THAT FACILITY WAS ACTIVATED A
HUNDRED AND ONE DAYS AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED FIFTEEN DAYS
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN TOTAL
ACROSS TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
GOVERNOR PROCLAIM SIXTEEN
EMERGENCIES.
WE REQUESTED AND RECEIVED THREE
PRESIDENTIAL MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATIONS IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE ALSO
REQUESTED AND RECEIVED TWELVE
FIRE MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
GRANTS IN THESE --
SIGNIFICANT IN THAT THE FIRE
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
FUNDING.
SO THAT WE CAN AVOID IT MAJOR
DISASTER DECLARATIONS AROSE AS A
RESULT OF FIRES.
AND SO TWELVE OF THOSE FIRE
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE GRANTS
WERE AWARDED IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS WAS SAID
EARLIER SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FIRES ONE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT FIRES HIT
SISKIYOU COUNTY IN A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
WAS THE KLAMATH FUND WE SAW THE
WEST FIRE DOWN NEAR THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OF GREAT SIGNIFICANCE THE
HOLIDAY FIRE AND SANTA BARBARA.
THE CAR FIRE THAT STRETCH FROM
SHASTA IN --
FROM TRINITY TO SHASTA COUNTIES
WE EXPERIENCE THREE CATEGORIZED
CATEGORY THREE TORNADO AND FORTY
THREE MILE AN HOUR WINDS.
SOMETHING THAT THE TRULY WAS
UNPRECEDENTED FIND CALIFORNIA
FIRE HISTORY --
WE EXPERIENCE THE CRANSTON FIRED
RIVERSIDE THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX
FIRE.
CONSUMED --
ACREAGE ACROSS FOUR COUNTIES IN
COLUSA GLENN LAKE IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY.
AT THE TIME WAS THE LARGEST FIRE --
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY FOR A FROM
A GROUP OF THE YEAR A NOVEMBER
EIGHTH --
AND INTO NOVEMBER WE EXPERIENCE
THE CAMPFIRE THE DEADLIEST FIRE
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY AS WELL AS
THE WALLS THE FIRE AND HELL
FIRES AND VENTURE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
LAST YEAR'S FIRES RESULTED IN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX LIVES
LOST MORE THAN ONE MILLION ACRES
BURNED AND TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
STRUCTURES BOTH HOMES AND
BUSINESSES JUST DESTROYED. TO
COMBAT THESE DEVASTATING FIRES --
CALLOW YES ENACTED.
UP THE PRE POSITIONING OF
RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THIS PRE POSITIONING OF FIRE AND
RESCUE RESOURCES PROVIDES QUICK
REACTION TIME TO STATE INCIDENTS
WHILE REASSURING COMMUNITIES
THAT THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STANDS READY TO
SUPPORT.
THOSE RESOURCES ARE PRE
POSITIONED READY AND AVAILABLE
TO COMBAT THE THREAT.
IN ITS IMMEDIATE START.
IN HOPES THAT IT DOES NOT
REACHED CATASTROPHIC LEVELS AND
THROUGHOUT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALLOW YES RECEIVED EIGHTY SIX
PRE POSITIONING REQUEST AND ALL
THOSE REQUESTS WERE FILLED.
AND IN MANY CASES THOSE PRE
POSITIONED RESOURCES WERE
UTILIZED AS INITIAL ATTACK TO
MINIMIZE THE FURTHER IMPACT OF
SIGNIFICANT FIRES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE --
THROUGH THAT PRE POSITIONING WE
SAW ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
FIREFIGHTERS FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCES PLACED IN STRATEGIC
LOCATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE RESPONSE
TIMES.
FIRE MUTUAL AID RESOURCES AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RESPONSE WERE
STRETCHED TO THE LIMITS.
SO IN ADDITION TO DOING THE PRE
POSITIONING CHIEF MARSHALL AND
HIS TEAM RESPONSIBLE --
FOR OVERSIGHT OF THE FIRE AND
RESCUE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM THE
FIRES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BEING
SOME OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
EXHAUSTED OUR AVAILABLE
RESOURCES AND MANY SITUATE AND
MANY CASES.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALLAWAY AS
COORDINATED ALMOST THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND RESOURCES THROUGH OUR
FIRE AND RESCUE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM.
ON THE JULY FIRES ALONE --
THE CAR AND MENDOCINO COMPLEXES
FROM OUT OF STATE. FOR THE
NOVEMBER WILD FIRES THE CAMP
HILL AND WALLS A THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ENGINES WERE BROUGHT
IN.
THIS REFLECTS THE MOST SEVERE
THREAT POSED TO FIRES.
IN THESE HIGHLY POPULATED AREAS
SUCH AS PARADISE IN MALIBU.
THE SHEER MAGNITUDE OF THE CAT
CATASTROPHIC NOVEMBER WILDFIRES
OVERWHELMED OUR ABILITY TO MEET
THE STATE'S NEED FOR ENGINES
WATER TENDERS AND OVERHEAD
PERSONNEL.
WE WERE UNABLE TO FILL THREE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE REQUESTS WE
RECEIVED FOR THE CAMP HILL AND
WALLS THE FIRES.
THAT AMOUNTED 261% OF ALL OF OUR
UNFILLED REQUESTS FOR THE ENTIRE
YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM OVERSEEN BY
CHIEF PAYS AN AND IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH.
WAS EXTREMELY BUSY OVER THE
COURSE TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR THE
CAMP FIRE OFFICERS AND
VOLUNTEERS CAME FROM FIFTY FIVE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES SIX DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING --
YES C. H. P. FISH AND WILDLIFE'S
STATE PARKS CORRECTIONS AN
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL.
AND THREE DIFFERENT FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO PERFORM VARIOUS LAW
ENFORCEMENT DUTIES DUTIES THIS
INCLUDES SEARCH AND RESCUE.
TRAFFIC CONTROL EVACUATIONS
PATROLLING PER TRACK PROTECTION
OF THOSE EVACUATED AREAS AND
CORNER SERVICES.
AS NOTED EARLIER OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES FROM ALLY STATE
AGENCIES TO PERFORM A VARIETY OF
FUNCTIONS AND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ROUND --
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT --
DEPLOYMENT OF ASSETS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
DEPLOYED AS PART OF THE WILD
FIRE RESPONSE.
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND SERVICE
MEMBERS MUTUAL AID --
THE MAJORITY OF THESE WERE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT DEPLOYED
EIGHTY AIRCRAFT IN SUPPORT OF
FIRE SUPPRESSION MEDICAL
EVACUATIONS.
AS WELL AS STRUCTURAL DAMAGE
ASSESSMENTS AND FIRE MAPPINGS AS
THE FIRES OCCURRING THAT
INFORMATION IS CRITICAL IN
HELPING US TO BUILD OUR REQUEST
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
SUPPORT.
AND SO THAT RAPID ASSESSMENT OF
DAMAGE -- IS
CRITICAL IN TOTAL OVER THREE
MILLION GALLONS OF WATER AND
FIRE RETARDANT WERE DROPPED.
TEN PERSONNEL WERE HELICOPTER
EVACUATED DUE TO THE RELATED
INJURIES WE HAD THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIRE PARAMETERS MATT
UTILIZING THE NATIONAL GUARDS
RESOURCES SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DAMAGE DESTROYED STRUCTURES WERE
ASSESSED AS PART OF THEIR
MISSION.
A TOTAL OF FOUR NATIONAL GUARD
ARMORY ALONG WITH SEVENTY SIX
SHUT INS WITH POWER GENERATION
WERE WRECKED IT FOR INCIDENT
COMMAND POSTS AND SHELTER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
IMPACTED AREA.
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT ALSO
PROVIDED EMERGENCY SATELLITE
COMMUNICATIONS AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCIDENT COMMAND
POST IN COUNTY EMERGENCY
OPERATION CENTERS.
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF THE
START OF THE CAMPFIRE DIRECTOR
GIL A DUTY REQUESTED FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION.
ANY ALSO REQUESTED OUT OF STATE
RESOURCES BE BROUGHT IN TO
RESPOND TO THE OVERWHELMING NEED.
RESOURCES CAME FROM SIXTEEN
STATES AND AS FAR AWAY AS
GEORGIA AND ALASKA.
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
COORDINATED RESOURCES AND MUTUAL
AID REQUEST IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND CONVENE IN
EVERY MAJOR EVENT THE STATE
UNIFIED COORDINATION GROUP WITH
FEMA.
EXECUTIVES FROM THROUGHOUT THE
GOVERNOR MINISTRATION AND ALL
STATE CRITICAL STATE AGENCIES.
DO YOU SEE JEAN MET DAILY AT
PALO WE HAVE ORDERS TO ASSESS
THE NEEDS ESTABLISH RESPONSE
PRIORITIES COORDINATE RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. TO ENSURE THAT DID
RESOURCES FROM ACROSS
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
HELLO YES IT ALSO ESTABLISHED
DURING THE RESPONSE MULTIPLE
TASK FORCES TO COORDINATE
COMPLEX RESPONSE EFFORTS WITH
OUR FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS.
THESE INCLUDED STE TASK FORCES
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
SHELTERING MASSACRE IN SUPPORT
OF THE POPULATIONS OF IMPACTED.
HOUSING TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS
THAT REQUIRED HOUSING ASSISTANCE
SCHOOLS TO DEAL WITH NOT ONLY
THE SCHOOLS WERE DESTROYED AS A
RESULT OF THE CAMPFIRE.
BUT THE NUMBER OF SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THEY WERE
IMPACTED AS RESULT OF SMOKING
IMPACTS FROM THE FIRES.
ANIMAL SHELTERING TASK FORCE WAS
ALSO ESTABLISHED AT THE CAMPFIRE.
TO SUPPORT THE BOTH PERSONAL
DOMESTIC ANIMALS AS WELL AS
LIVESTOCK AND OTHER ANIMALS THAT
WERE DISPLACED AS A RESULT OF
THE FIRE --
IN WERE REMAINING IN THE BURN
AREA AND SO SUPPORT OF THEM
FEEDING AND SHELTERING FOR THEM
WAS KEY.
WE ALSO ESTABLISHED WATERSHED
TASK FORCE IN THE DEBRIS TASK
FORCE THAT ARE STILL FUNCTIONAL
TO THIS DAY THE WATERSHED TASK
FORCE IS BEING UTILIZED EVEN
TODAY.
AS WE HAVE STORMS COMING AND
EXTRACTING THE BURNING AREAS TO
GET AHEAD OF POTENTIAL MUDSLIDES
AND DEBRIS FLOWS IN THESE AREAS
AND THE DEBRIS TASK FORCES
OVERSEEING --
WHAT WILL LIKELY BE THE LARGEST
DEBRIS REMOVAL OPERATION
CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY?
HELLO YES COLLABORATED WITH OUR
LOCAL AND FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
OPEN LOCAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
AND DISASTER RECOVERY CENTERS IN
ALL THE IMPACTED COUNTIES.
PROVIDING RESEARCH THE RESOURCES
THAT SURVIVORS RECEIVED THROUGH
THESE INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS INCLUDE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE CRISIS COUNSELING.
DISASTER UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
LEGAL SERVICES AND ALSO
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITIOUS
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE. FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER --
AS A RESULT OF THESE WE'RE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER RECOVERY FRAMEWORK IN
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
IMMOBILIZING.
THE RESPONSE RECOVERY FUNCTIONS
THAT ABOUT ESTABLISH A FEDERAL
LEVEL THIS FRAMEWORK --
BILLS ON THE STATE'S EXPERIENCE
AND RECOVERY DOCUMENTS AND
GUIDANCE.
AND WILL ALLOW US TO EFFECTIVELY
DEAL WITH THE LONG TERM
MANAGEMENT ACROSS THE MULTITUDE
OF AREAS FROM COMMUNITY PLANNING
CAPACITY BUILDING.
ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF ARE
IMPACTED AREAS THE HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT WILL BE
GOING ON GOING FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME.
HELLO YES IS ALSO ADMINISTERING
THE PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WHICH IS THE POP POP PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO REIMBURSE
JURISDICTIONS FOR BOTH THEIR
RESPONSE COST AS WELL AS REPAIR.
OF THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS
DAMAGED.
IN RESPONSE TO THE EVENTS THAT
WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT THAT WERE
DECLARED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALLOW YES IS CONDUCTED
BRIEFINGS TO THE PRESS TO
PREPARE.
APPLICATIONS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HELP THEM DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY AND DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS --
WE'VE SO FAR HELD TWENTY SIX
APPLICANT BRIEFINGS ACROSS THE
STATE.
WE EXPECT ACROSS THE THREE MAJOR
DISASTERS.
THE WEEK TO OBLIGATE THE MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF
THE CAMP HILL AND WILL SEE FIRES.
AND FINALLY --
SOME SIGNIFICANT FIRST WORK
EXPERIENCE ARE RESPONSE TO THE
EVENTS IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR THE FIRST
TIME UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR
HISTORY WE DEPLOYED FORENSIC
SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS IN
SUPPORT OF BUTTE COUNTY ON THE
CAMPFIRE. TO METHODICALLY SEARCH
EACH AND EVERY PRETTY --
WHERE STRUCTURE BURNED FOR THE
REMAINS OF THE VICTIMS OF THAT
FIRE?
ALSO DEPLOYED MEDICAL HEALTH
TEAMS WERE INTEGRATED WITH OUR
SHELTER OPERATIONS FAMILY
SUPPORT CENTER WAS ESTABLISHED.
DIRECTED DIRECTLY HELP THE NEXT
OF KIN OF A INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
LOST IN THE FIRE HELPING THEM
NAVIGATE THE MULTITUDE OF
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE TO THEM --
WE ESTABLISHED THE FIRST MAKE A
DISASTER RECOVERY CENTER LARGEST
DISASTER RECOVERY CENTER THAT'S
EVER BEEN SET UP IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY IN CHICO --
TO SUPPORT THE SURVIVORS OF THE
CAMP FIRE --
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE
ANIMAL SUPPORT OPERATIONS
PERHAPS THE LARGEST ANIMAL
SUPPORT OPERATION IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY IN THE CAMP FIRE --
AND AS WAS INDICATED EARLIER THE
DEBRIS REMOVAL OPERATION IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON CLEAN UP OF
ASH AND DEBRIS FROM MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND PROPERTIES --
AND THAT'S JUST IN THE NORTH
FIRE ALONE THERE'S OVER A
THOUSAND PROPERTIES IN LA IN
PRINTER COUNTY THAT WERE ALSO --
CLEARING ASH AND DEBRIS SO THAT
WE CAN FACILITATE GETTING FOLKS
IN SOME CASES BACK ONTO THEIR
PROPERTY TO LIVE TEMPORARILY --
IN IN OTHER CASES INDIVIDUALS TO
HAVE A CLEAR CLEAN PROPERTY THAT
THEY CAN BEGIN THE REBUILDING
PROCESS.
HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ACTUALLY TURNED
BACK OVER TO GRACE TO TALK A
LITTLE GREATER DETAIL ABOUT OUR
RECOVERY REIMBURSEMENT.
PROGRAMS UNLESS THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS NO I THINK HELEN M.
KIND OF OUTLINE THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT AND THAT
WAS THE THE FUNDING MECHANISM.
BY WHICH WE SUPPORT THE LOCALS --
DUE TO THE OVERWHELMING NATURE
OF IT NOT ONLY FUNDS --
IT WE CAN FIND THE CITIES THIS.
THE COUNTY SPECIAL DISTRICTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS --
TO ADDRESS THEIR EMERGENCY
DISASTER RESPONSE FOR STEAK
PROCLAIMED EMERGENCIES THE
REPAIR OR REPLACEMENT OF PUBLIC
PROPERTY DAMAGED OR DESTROYED BY
THE EMERGENCY.
AND WE CAN ALSO --
PROVIDE THE SOME OF THE MATCHING
FUND THAT HELEN SPOKE TO FOR
COST SHARING REQUIRED --
FOR EXAMPLE IF IT'S A SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE DISASTER WE CAN
FIND A PORTION OF THE LOCAL
CARSHARE THROUGH THIS MECHANISM --
IN GENERAL ED TYPICALLY THE
SHARE IS NO MORE THAN 75% OF
THOSE ELIGIBLE COSTS.
SO THE ELIGIBLE COSTS INCLUDE
OVER TIME AND THE OVERTIME
ASSOCIATED WAGE FOR ADDED COST
FOR THE RESPONSE NOT TYPICALLY
YOUR NORMAL BASE SALARY ACTUAL
TRAVEL AND PER DIEM SUPPLIES
MATERIALS AND EQUIPMENT.
REPAIR PERMANENT RESTORATION A
REPLACEMENT COSTS COSTS FOR
PUBLIC FACILITIES.
THE COST OF BASIC ENGINEERING
SERVICES FOR WHICH THOSE ARE
NECESSARY FOR AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COST AND COST FOR WORK PERFORMED
UNDER INTER AGENCY ASSISTANCE --
IT WHETHER IT'S THROUGH ANOTHER
STATE AGENCY OR A UNIVERSITY.
AND THE LOCAL CULTURE IS
REQUIRED UNDER THE FEDERAL
FEDERAL PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
AND UNDER THAT --
THE STATE IF THE TWENTY FIVE IF
IT IS FEDERALLY COST SHARED.
THE STATE WOULD FURTHER CARSHARE
WITH THE LOCALS SO THAT 25%
WOULD BE --
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN AND A POINT
SEVEN FIVE FOR THE STATE AND SIX
AND A QUARTER FOR THE LOCALS.
SEWED SO EVERYONE HAS A STAKE IN
THE IN THE CONTROLLING AND
MANAGING OF THOSE COST
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ALL CONTINUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WEBER
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE VIA
BOARD MY NAME IS HOLLY PORTER
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND I'M ENTERING MY EIGHTH YEAR
IN THIS ROLE AND MY AIM TODAY IS
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AN OVERVIEW
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FROM THE
LOCAL PERSPECTIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE.
HOW WE WORK WITH CARILLO YES AND
GAPS THAT I SEE FROM A MORE
GRANULAR AT THE GROUND LEVEL?
SO WHAT'S AN EMERGENCY MANAGER
WELL YOU COULD SAY THAT I AM A
PAID PESSIMIST.
I AM A PAID TO THINK ALL DAY
ABOUT WORST CASE SCENARIOS AND
HOW WE CAN WORK TO MAKE
DISASTERS LESS IMPACTFUL WHEN
THEY DO HAPPEN.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR STATE IS SEEN
SEVERAL HISTORICALLY DEVASTATING
DISASTERS IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WHICH HAS A FIRM TO THE
NEED FOR A STRONG AND ROBUST
STATE AND LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT CAPABILITY.
IN A REAL SENSE SUCCESSFUL
EMERGENCY MANAGERS ARE LIKE
CONDUCTORS.
WE KEEP THE ORCHESTRA OF PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL AND SANK BY
MEDIATING.
FACILITATING AND COMMUNICATING
NGUYEN FIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
MEDICAL SERVICES PUBLIC WORKS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
SO I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU A REAL
WORLD SCENARIO TO DEMONSTRATE
WHAT EMERGENCY MANAGERS DO AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND WHY THEY'RE SO CRITICAL TO
SUCCESSFUL DISASTER RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY EFFORT.
LET'S SAY THERE'S A FAST MOVING
FIRE THAT BREAKS OUT IN A
FICTIONAL TOWN THAT WILL CALL ME
VERY.
CALIFORNIA.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THE
FIRST TO ARRIVE ON SCENE SHE
GOES DOOR TO DOOR URGING
RESIDENTS TO EVACUATE
IMMEDIATELY TO A TEMPORARY
EVACUATION POINT.
AT THE LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL NEAR BY.
THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC
INFORMATION OFFICER GETS THIS
INFORMATION FROM DISPATCHING
TWEETS OUT FIRE IN MAYBERRY
EVACUATIONS IN PROGRESS
TEMPORARY EVACUATION POINT IS
MAYBERRY UNION HIGH SCHOOL.
WHILE THE OFFICERS WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF
HARM'S WAY FIRE PERSONNEL ARRIVE
ON SCENE ESTABLISH UNIFIED
COMMAND WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND BEGIN ASSESSING THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL EVACUATIONS AND FIRE
RESOURCES.
FIRE PERSONNEL NOTIFY THE
MAYBERRY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ABOUT THE
FAST MOVING FIRE AND THEY
REQUESTED EMERGENCY MANAGER
FIELD LIAISON AT THEIR COMMAND
POST.
THE DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES FOR MAYBERRY
IMMEDIATELY DISPATCH AS A STAFF
MEMBER TO THE LOCATION WHERE
THAT COMMAND STAFF IS GATHERED
FIRE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THAT EMERGENCY MANAGER
BEGINS COMMUNICATING WITH THE
COUNTY'S EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER.
EMERGENCY MANAGERS AT THAT
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER ARE
CONTACTING THE AMERICAN RED
CA RED CROSS.
THEY'RE REQUESTING CANTEEN
SERVICES IT'S THE HIGH SCHOOL
AND THEIR INFORMING THE RED
CROSS THAT AN OVERNIGHT SHELTER
MAY BE NEEDED.
MAYBERRY COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGERS CALL THE HIGH SCHOOL
JUST TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW THE
OF THOSE INCOMING GAS.
LOCAL EMERGENCY MANAGERS ARE
LOOKING TO SEE IF MAJOR HIGHWAYS
MAY BE IMPACTED BY THE FIRE OR
IN THE CASE OF MAYBERRY IT COULD
BE THE ONLY ROAD IN AND OUT OF
THAT COMMUNITY.
MIGHT THERE BE A NEED FOR A
LARGE ANIMAL EVACUATIONS IF SO A
CALL FOR ASSISTANCE MAY BE
NEEDED TO COUNTY ANIMAL SERVICES.
SO THE FIRST PRIORITY IS
MOBILIZING EMERGENCY PERSONNEL
AND RESOURCES.
EMERGENCY MANAGERS ARE STAFFING
UP THE PUBLIC INFORMATION CALL
CENTER THEY'RE COORDINATING FOR
MASS CARE AND FEEDING ALERTING
COUNTY DAMAGE ASSESSMENT TEAMS
AND PUTTING COUNTY STAFF ON CALL
OR ON STAND BY FOR TO SET UP A
LOCAL ASSISTANCE CENTER.
MARY EMERGENCY MANAGERS ARE ALSO
CONTACTING THE TERRITORIAL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR CALLOW YES
AND THEIR NOTIFYING THE STATE
WARNING CENTER.
EMERGENCY MANAGERS IN MAYBERRY
ARE ASSISTING WITH BOTH
UNINCORPORATED AREA PUBLIC ALERT
AND WARNING CALLS AND HELPING
CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY
INITIATE MASS NOTIFICATION
MESSAGES WHEN ASSISTANCE IS
NEEDED.
PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICERS ARE
CALLED TO WORK AT THE MAY VERY
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER TO
ASSIST WITH SOCIAL MEDIA PRESS
CONFERENCES MEDIA CALLS AND
WEBSITE UPDATES.
THE DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS UPDATING THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY'S
CHIEF EXECUTIVES.
ALL OF THIS THAT I JUST
DESCRIBED TO YOU IS HAPPENING
WITH WITHIN JUST THE FIRST FEW
MINUTES OF THAT FIRE BREAKING
OUT.
SO WHAT I'VE DESCRIBED HERE SOME
OF THE ACTION CENTRAL TO
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
MOBILIZING EMERGENCY PERSONNEL
AND RESOURCES PUBLIC ALERT AND
WARNING MASS CARE AND FEEDING
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR PUBLIC
INFORMATION COORDINATING
MESSAGING AMONG VARIOUS AGENCIES
AND ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED IN
THE DISASTER RESPONSE.
WERE INVOLVED IN THE
COORDINATION OF LIFELINE
RESTORATION LIKE WATER POWER
POWER FUEL NATURAL GAS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
AND THEN THERE'S THE LONG
JOURNEY OF DISASTER RECOVERY
FROM DAMAGE ASSESSMENT TO DEBRIS
REMOVAL TO LONG AND SHORT SHORT
TERM HOUSING SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND RESTORATION OF
CULTURAL AND NATURAL RESOURCES.
IN SHORT IT'S A BIG JOB SO
IMAGINE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN ALL OF
THOSE CRITICAL AND IMMEDIATE
ACTIONS ARE EXPECTED OF AN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT STAFF OF
ONE OR TO THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENS IN MANY CITIES.
AND COUNTIES HERE IN OUR STATE.
MEANWHILE DISASTERS OF HISTORIC
PROPORTIONS ARE OCCURRING
REGULARLY.
THERE'S A WELL KNOWN SAYING IN
OUR INDUSTRY THAT ARE ALL
DISASTERS ARE LOCAL.
WELL THE EXTENT TO WHICH THEY
REMAIN LOCAL DEPENDS UPON THE
INVESTMENT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PERSONNEL TRAINING AND EQUIPMENT.
NECESSARY TO PREPARE FOR RESPOND
TO AND RECOVER FROM DISASTERS.
I'M INCREDIBLY FORTUNATE TO WORK
FOR HAS INVESTED HEAVILY IN
THESE CAPABILITIES.
I HAVE FIFTEEN NON
ADMINISTRATIVE EMERGENCY
MANAGERS WHO ARE CHARGED WITH
ACCOMPLISHING ALL THE ACTIONS
I'VE DESCRIBED TODAY BUT THIS IS
NOT COMMON. ONE SIZE DOES NOT
FIT ALL WHEN IT COMES TO
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA.
TYPICALLY AND SOME MID SIZED AND
AND SMALLER CITIES AND EVEN SOME
COUNTY'S.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HAS FEW IF
ANY STAFF RESOURCES.
HOWEVER THEY'RE VERY ROLE
REQUIRES INTEGRATION AND
COORDINATION WITH MANY CITY AND
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND SOME LOCAL COMMUNITIES THE
EMERGENCY MANAGERS ONE POSITION
THAT'S BURIED IN THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND OF EITHER FIRE OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SOME JURISDICTIONS A SIGN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AS OTHER
DUTIES AS ASSIGNED TO AN ANALYST
OR SOMEONE EVEN IN PUBLIC WORKS.
EFFECTIVE EMERGENCY MANAGERS
MUST DISPLAY SPECIALIZED JOB
KNOWLEDGE AWARENESS OF CURRENT
PENDING LEGISLATION.
FAMILIARITY WITH REGULATIONS
EXPERIENCE WITH PLANNING
TRAINING AND DRILLS AND A
WORKING KNOWLEDGE OF FEDERAL
TRIBAL STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
ALL ASSOCIATED WITH EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A FULLY
CAPABLE WELL RESOURCE LOCAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT CAPABILITY
THE STATE MUST.
BACK FILL.
MOBILIZING PEOPLE AND RESOURCES
TAKES TIME AND TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE WHEN IT COMES TO
DISASTER RESPONSE. FOR SAN DIEGO
COUNTY THE STATE IS A SAFETY NET
WHEN LOCAL RESOURCES ARE
EXHAUSTED AND STATE OR FEDERAL
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED.
ANYTIME WE ACTIVATE OUR
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER WE
HAVE A CALLOW YES REPRESENTATIVE
SITTING SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
WITH US.
THIS FACILITATES COMMUNICATION
TO THE STATE'S SOUTHERN REGION
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER AND
THEIR ABILITY TO KEEP THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE INFORMED.
CALLAWAY YES STAFF OR THERE
DURING THE TO ASSIST US IN
GETTING THE NECESSARY PERSONNEL
EQUIPMENT AND RESOURCES THAT WE
CAN'T FIND WITHIN OUR OWN COUNTY.
WHEN IT COMES TO RESPONSE THE
STATE'S POSTURE UNDER DIRECTOR
GIL DO CHEESE LEADERSHIP IS
PROACTIVE AND FORWARD LEANING?
THEY DEPLOY EARLY AND RETREAT
LATER IF THE SITUATION WARRANTS
WE'VE APPRECIATED THE
RESPONSIVENESS AND AVAILABILITY
OF CALLOW YES DURING SOME OF THE
TOUGHEST DAYS OUR COMMUNITY IS
FACED.
FOLLOWING THE LILAC FIRE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THE STATE
EMBEDDED STAFF FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME IN OUR RECOVERY
OPERATIONS CENTER.
NAVIGATING THE MYRIAD OF
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND
APPLICATION PROCESSES FOR STATE
AND FEDERAL PUBLIC AN INDIVIDUAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS CAN BE VERY
DAUNTING.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RELY UPON
CALLOW YES FOR THEIR SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND AND DISASTER
RECOVERY IN GENERAL.
MY OFFICE IS IN DAILY CONTACT
WITH SOMEONE FROM CALLOW YES WE
MIGHT BE IN CONTACT REGARDING
HOMELAND SECURITY GRANT
INVESTMENTS.
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANNING OR
DISASTER PLANNING FOR PEOPLE
WITH ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
[inaudible] FOR FOR EXAMPLE.
HELLO YES MAYBE CONSULTING WITH
US AS THEY WRITE NEW STATEWIDE
GUIDANCE ON ANY NUMBER OF TOPICS
WE TALK WITH EACH OTHER IN
ADVANCE OF DURING AND AFTER A
MAJOR WEATHER EVENTS.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE
COLLABORATE AND COORDINATE DAILY
WITH CALLOW YES STAFF AND
CONSIDER THEM PART OF OUR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT TEAM.
RECENTLY CALLOW YES LAUNCHED AN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM THIS
PROVIDES A BENCHMARK DEFINING
THE STANDARDS AND EXPERIENCE
NEEDED TO BE CONSIDERED A
QUALIFIED EMERGENCY MANAGER.
BY SETTING STANDARDS CALLOW YES
IS TAKING THE LEAD AND
PROFESSIONAL ISING ARE
DISCIPLINE.
BUT THE GAPS I SEE YOU'RE
RELATED TO SHEER NUMBERS.
NO ONE QUESTIONS THE NEED FOR
BIG RED OR BIG BLUE.
THE PURPOSE AND MISSION OF FIRE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT IS WELL
KNOWN AND WIDELY UNDERSTOOD.
HOWEVER FOURTEEN YEARS AFTER
HURRICANE KATRINA THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FUNCTION STILL
STRUGGLES TO GET BIG ENOUGH FAST
ENOUGH TO ACCOMPLISH THE MISSION
AT HAND.
AND THE MISSION OF COURSE IS
ABOUT SAVING LIVES IN PROTECTING
PROPERTY.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY
WHEN I SAY.
I WORK IN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
AND THE PERSON WHO'S CUTTING MY
HAIR DOESN'T RESPOND BACK --
SO YOU DRIVE AN AMBULANCE.
IN THIS CONTEXT I WILL TAKE OFF
MY PESSIMIST HAT AND SAY.
I BELIEVE WE'LL GET THERE.
I JUST PRAY IT DOESN'T TAKE
SEVERAL MORE DEVASTATING
DISASTERS TO PROVE THAT ROBUST
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT STAFFING AT
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL IN THIS
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX THREAT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE LIVE IN.
CHARMING THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS PENDING ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
PANELISTS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDING TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM RAIMENT
RIORDAN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EXCEPT THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE.
BEFORE STARTING AT SAN JOSE.
I'M MIGHT LOOK TWENTY FIVE BUT I
HAVE THIRTY ONE YEARS EXPERIENCE
AN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AT THE
LOCAL THE COUNTY THE STATE.
AND FEDERAL RESPONSE LEVELS
INCLUDING WORK WITH A SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
IN ADDITION I'M CURRENTLY THE
STATE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION.
THAT REPRESENTS OVER THREE SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBERS.
WHO ARE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
MANAGERS AND CITIES COUNTIES
PUBLIC HEALTH MEDICAL HEALTH AND
PRIVATE SECTORS WHILE? ONE OF
SEIZE US THAT'S THE ACRONYM FOR
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION OUR MISSION
IS TO WORK WITH CALORIE US TO
SUPPORT.
PLANNING TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FIELD.
I'M HERE TO DATE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE CONDITION OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
AT THE LOCAL CITY LEVEL.
ANY RELATIONSHIP TO OUR VOTE
RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES OR CALORIE US.
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH CALLAWAY
THIS IS GOOD.
AND LIKE ALL RELATIONSHIPS
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
OUR EXPERIENCE WITH LOCAL LONG
FIRE THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IS
TREMENDOUS AS RESULTS BUT AS
DIRECTOR LIBERAL INDICATED THAT.
MEDICINE PORT RECEIVED IN
RESPONSE TO DISASTERS.
CALLAWAY US IN THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY.
ARE BOTH AGREE AND TEACHER THEIR
COURSES THAT DISASTERS ARE LOCAL.
LOCAL POLICE FIRE AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ARE THE FIRST TO
RESPOND.
THE FIRST TO TAKE ACTION.
THE FIRST TO MAKE DECISIONS ON A
LEARNING AND WARNING.
IT IS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT
HAS TO MANAGE THE RECOVERY
FOLLOWING THE DISASTER.
WE THE FIRST TO WHOM THE PUBLIC
LOOKS EXPECTED FERMENTATION
DECISIONS AND COMMUNITY FOCUS
LEADERSHIP.
WE NEED TO DEMONSTRATE A VISION
OF COMPASSION IN ACTION.
WHILE MEETING THE PUBLIC'S BASIC
NEEDS.
WHILE DISASTROUS TRULY OUR LOCAL
WE ALWAYS LOOK TO CALORIE AS FOR
THE LEADERSHIP AND GAUGE BENT.
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER AN
EMERGENCY.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
AGAIN DIRECT LINE ROAD DID
INDICATE THE INCREASED NUMBER OF
DISASTERS THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING.
AND BY DEFINITION DISASTER
CONDITIONS EXCEED.
THE NORMAL CAPABILITIES OF LOCAL
POLICE FIRE MEDICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
REQUIRES RESPONSE AND
PROFESSIONALISM OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PERSONNEL.
WHO PLAN TRAINED AND ORGANIZE
RESOURCES AND FACILITIES?
IN RESPONSE TO THE CATASTROPHIC
INCIDENCES LIKE THE CURRENT
FLOODS.
THE LAST TWO YEARS OF FIRES IN
BUTTE SO NO MY NAPA COUNTIES.
AND FOR OUR OVERDUE FUTURE
CATASTROPHIC EARTHQUAKE IN
SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
YES WE ARE PESSIMISTS.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PROFESSIONALS ARE THE ONES WHO
DEVELOP THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT THE VISION OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ELECTED OFFICIALS.
EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT AND
RESPONSE OFFICIALS.
IT IS THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PROFESSIONAL.
WHO PREPARES THOSE PLANTS
PROCEDURES IN THE WARNING
SYSTEMS?
IS A LOCAL EMERGENCY MANAGER HER
LEARN.
AND PLANS AND EXECUTES HIS
OBLIGATIONS IN COORDINATION WITH
CALORIE YES.
AS CALLOW YES IS RESPONSIBLE.
FOR MANY THINGS OF WE DISCUSSED
TODAY INCLUDING THE COORDINATION
OF MUTUAL AID.
THE PROCLAMATION EMERGENCY
PROCESS.
POST DISASTER FUNDS FROM FEMA
AND PRE DISASTER FUNDING STREAMS.
THE FUNDING STREAMS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE THROUGH CALORIE US TO
SUPPORT EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ARE
INSUFFICIENT.
THEY RELY A LOT ON FEDERAL
BUDGET APPROVALS AND REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT MANAGEMENT OP
PROCESS SEES.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS STE
CHALLENGE THEM TO SUSTAIN AN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
WITHIN THESE LIMITED FUNDS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FOR PERFECT POSITIONS.
HAVE BEEN EITHER ELIMINATED DUE
TO BUDGET CUTS IN THE RECESSION.
OR THERE MINIMIZED AND BECAUSE A
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ROLE FOCUS AND PURPOSE OF WHAT
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT CAN'T
PROVIDE THE LOCAL JURISDICTION.
AS RESULT EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED
OR CONTINUE BE UNDER FUNDED.
BASIC PLANS EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER PROPONENTS ARE FREQUENTLY
OUT OF DATE AS A RESULT.
IN MANY CASES THE ROLE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
HAS BEEN DELEGATED TO LAW OR
FIRE STAFF.
AS AN ADDITIONAL DUTY ON TOP ALL
THOSE OTHER PRIMARY LIFE SAFETY
TASKS.
THE FUNDS THAT ARE AVAILABLE DO
NOT MAKE IT SOMETIMES TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IN MANY CASES THE FUNDING
STREAMS STOP AT THE OPERATIONAL
AREA WHICH IS THE JURISDICTION
BOUNDARIES OF THE COUNTY.
AN REPRESENTATIVES OF MEMBERS UP
WITHIN THAT AREA --
BUT DON'T MAKE IT TO ACTUALLY
LOCAL THE CITY GOVERNMENT. FOR
EXAMPLE IS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THE STATE HOMELAND SECURITY
GRANTS EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM PERFORMANCE GRANTS.
DO NOT CORRECT DIRECTLY GO TO
CITY PROGRAMS.
THEY'RE DIVIDED AMONG OTHER
PROGRAMS BY THE OP AREA.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHEN
THE STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT'S
REGULATIONS WERE PUBLISHED.
SAM'S BECAME THE GUIDING BEACON
FOR PLANTS TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION.
I WAS PROUD TO SIT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S ADVISORY BOARD THAT
HELPED CREATE THE PROGRAM.
I IT WAS NEW AND INNOVATIVE.
IT WAS SO EFFECTIVE THAT AFTER
NINE ELEVEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CLEAN THE CONCEPTS
AND PROGRAMS OF SAM'S. TO CREATE
THE NATIONAL INCIDENT MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM TO WHICH WE ALSO REQUIRED
TO FOLLOW.
SAM'S IS CRITICAL IT'S CRITICAL
FOR OUR EXPECTS BUT IT MUTUAL
AID STANDARDIZING RESPONSE.
BETWEEN OUR GOVERNMENT LEVELS.
AN ACCREDITING A CREDENTIALING
IS PRODUCT.
THE SUMS PROTOCOLS HOWEVER HAVE
BECOME OUTDATED AND NEED TO
REBOOT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WANTS TO WORK
WITH CARILLO YES TO UPDATE AND
REFRESH THE SAM SYSTEM.
BECAUSE SO MUCH HAS BEEN LEARNED
ABOUT DISASTER RESPONSE RECOVERY
OVER THESE TWENTY THREE YEARS.
TO GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
OF HEALTH SERVICES CAN BE A
CHALLENGE.
SPECIFICALLY TO SAN JOSE.
IF YOU STRICTLY INTERPRET THE
SAM'S REGULATIONS CALORIE US
PERSONNEL.
CANNOT DIRECTLY COMMUNICATE WITH
SAN JOSE THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE COUNTY FOR INFORMATION.
CONDITIONS FOR DIRECT CONTACT
BETWEEN CALAVERAS AND THE CITY.
CAN MAKE SENSE AND NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED.
RECOVERY FROM A DISASTROUS
DIFFICULT.
IT TAKES FREQUENT TWISTS AND
TURNS AND LEAVES GAPS IN FULL
RECOVERY.
HELLO YES.
IS EXPERIENCING THE GRAYSON ARMY
RETIREMENTS THE EXPERIENCE OF SO
MANY.
AND SO MANY NEW STAFF FOR COMING
ON COLLEGE BASIS LEAVING AND
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
AS WELL.
TRAINING IN UNDERSTANDING THE
RECOVERY PATH IS CRITICAL FOR
BOTH STATE AND LOCAL PERSONNEL.
DURING OUR INITIAL RECOVERY FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
COUNTY CREEK FLOOD.
WE HAD NO LESS THAN FIVE CALLOW
YES.
PRIMARY CONTACTS REPLACE EACH
OTHER.
EACH HAVE THEIR OWN
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT WAS
NEEDED TO ESTABLISH A CLAIM.
WHICH MADE THE TASK OF
INITIATING RECOVERY VERY
DIFFICULT.
WITH THE FREQUENCY DISASTERS
INCREASING.
RECOVERY HOUSE TO BECOME SECOND
NATURE.
HELLO YES NEEDS TO WORK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT DEVELOPING A
MORE CLEANLY DEFINED RECOVERY
PROTOCOLS SYSTEM.
RECOVERY IS NOT EVEN PART OF THE
SAMS PROCESS.
ANOTHER REASON FOR THE
INTEGRATION UPDATE OF SAM'S.
UNDERSTANDING HOW CALORIE US THE
TERMS THE SUPPORT OF LOCAL
PROCLAMATION OF EMERGENCY.
NEEDS TO BE REFRESHED IN JUST
THE AND DISCUSSED AMONGST THE
AGENCIES.
HISTORICALLY UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN IT WAS ROUTINE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE
AMENDMENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT.
GRANT.
PRIOR TO DISASTER SINCE THEN THE
HASN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN EVERY YEAR
IT TYPICALLY FUNDED AFTER A
DISASTER.
BOB THIS ALSO THE DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY THE TIGHTS EMERGENCIES
WE SAW DECLARED BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WE'RE NO LONGER
DECLARE EMERGENCIES EVEN THOUGH
IT HAD SO MANY.
OTHERS NOT DECLARED AS OFTEN.
ARE THE IMPACTS THE UP THE FACT
THAT THIS WORK RIVERS AS WE SEE
TODAY.
ARE SIGNIFICANT AND LANDING TO A
VISION OF FUTURE FREQUENT THAT
DECORATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
BY IN THE DECLARATION OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHAT THE
ISSUES THAT WE FACE THE SAN JOSE
IS THAT INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE
WAS NOT PART OF THE DECORATION.
BUT IT WAS SORELY NEEDED BY OUR
PUBLIC WE WERE VERY FORTUNATE
WITH THE DONATIONS OF OVER SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION.
THAT WE AS A CITY DEVELOPED OUR
OWN INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AT THAT TIME TO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC.
WELL THESE ARE AREAS OF CONCERN
WE DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE CARILLO
YES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
WE SHOULD BE COMMENDED FOR THE
BACK FILL THE STATE PROPERTIES
LOST -- AT
THE PROP THE TO ME THE STATE
PROPERTY TAXES I COLLECTED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AFFECTED BY
THESE RECENT WILDFIRES THAT WAS
A GREAT MOVE.
TECHNOLOGY ALSO NEEDS TO BE
ADVANCED IN THE FEEL OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
THE CURRENT STATEWIDE DATE IN
SITUATIONS STATUS REPORTING
SYSTEM MAINTAINED BY CALORIE US.
IS WOEFULLY OUTPACED BY OTHER
AVAILABLE SYSTEMS.
THE ATTEMPT TO CREATING A COMMON
OPERATING PICTURE IS CRITICAL
AND NECESSARY DURING RESPONSE.
UNTIL RECENTLY THE CURRENT
SYSTEM KNOWN AS CAL E. LIKE CAL
D. O. C. TYPING AT THE RIGHT.
ARM HAS NOT BEEN AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
USE OR INTEGRATION --
IF A DISASTER IS LOCAL IN THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
IS LOCAL.
DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO DEVELOP A
SYSTEM FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL UP.
TO THE STATE.
AN INTEGRATED THE CONCEPTS AND
ISSUES THAT WE BOTH HAVE IN
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY.
IN CONCLUSION.
WHAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
INVESTMENTS AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT WHAT ARE THEY AND
WHAT DO THEY MEAN?
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE A BILLING SCIENCE FOR
EVERYONE DOLLAR INVESTED
PREPAREDNESS MITIGATION
ACTIVITIES. SIX DOLLARS AN
RECOVERY COSTS ARE SAVED.
IT IS BETTER TO FOCUS ON
PLANNING TRAINING MITIGATING A
CONCERT WITH EACH OTHER.
THAT SPENT ALL OUR RESOURCES
TRYING TO RECOVER FROM THE LAST
DISASTER.
WE NEED A ROBUST INSIST STATE
INVESTMENT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
READY NESS AND RESILIENCE.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME RECENTLY
COMMENTED THAT THERE WAS A NEW
NORMAL IN THE GLOBAL DISASTER
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA.
HE FURTHER NOTED THAT THE HOT
SEASON IT'S HOTTER.
THE WET SEASON IS WATER.
HIS BUDGET CALLS FOR GREAT
DEVELOPS FOR TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPMENT OF SUCH THINGS THE
NEW WARNING SYSTEM THE
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM WHICH
IS NEEDED.
NOT ALL THESE PROGRAMS MAY NOT
ALL THESE PROGRAMS ARE NOT REACH
DOWN TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WE'RE HERE TO ASK THE
DIALOGUE ON THESE ISSUES THAT I
REYES AND OTHERS.
CAN BE COVERED THOUGHT I COULD
COME OF ALL THIS TIME FOR A BILL
THAT WE CAN.
OPEN THESE DIALOGUES.
BOB WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT VOMIT
TO CONTINUE THE GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE CAL WITH
CALORIE US.
AND ALLOW US TO BE OPEN HONEST
AND DIRECT AND HOW WE CAN MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TOGETHER.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS ASKING FOR
SEAT AT THE TABLE AN ENGAGEMENT
OF THESE EFFORTS.
I THANK YOU --
DID YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THE
SYSTEM.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS --
YOU MENTIONED THAT SOME OF YOU
HAVE --
PERSONS WHO IS IN CHARGE OF
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND THAT'S
SPECIFICALLY THAT JOB.
DO WE KNOW HOW MANY COUNTIES
HAVE THAT.
WE HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON SO
EVERY CALIFORNIA COUNTY HAS AN
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
RIGHT AS HOLLY A VERY ELOQUENTLY --
ILLUSTRATED.
IT RUNS THE GAMUT FROM THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY THAT HAS I THINK
OVER A DOZEN STAFF TO A MODOC
COUNTY THAT HAS.
AN INDIVIDUAL DOING IT ALONG
WITH FOUR OTHER DUTIES WITHIN
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
SO -- IN THE
YES OFFICES ARE ORGANIZED A DIFF --
I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBERS
IN FRONT OF ME BUT ACROSS THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES --
MOST OF THEM --
WOULD PROBABLY TWO THIRDS OF
THEM ARE AT IN IN EITHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR FIRE.
BUT THE REST ARE ORGANIZED IN CA
OWES OFFICE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICES --
PUBLIC WORKS OFFICES --
AND THE COMMITMENT THAT THOSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE MADE TO
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IS
DIFFERENT COUNTY TO COUNTY AND A
LOT OF THAT IS DRIVEN BY.
THEIR EXPERIENCES THOSE
JURISDICTIONS SIMILAR TO SAN
DIEGO THAT HAVE --
OVER THE LAST DECADE PLUS
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT EVENTS.
HAVE HAVE.
I HAVE COMMITTED --
EIGHT EIGHT TWO THEIR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM --
BUT A LOT OF JURISDICTIONS I
THINK IT CONTINUES TO BE AN
EDUCATION FOLKS ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT --
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE AND EMS
PERSONNEL DO VERY HEROICALLY.
AND THE COMMITMENT OF OF
RESOURCES --
IS IS PROVIDED THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS THE SAME --
BECAUSE OF THAT AGAINST
AMBIGUOUS NATURE MANAGEMENT --
SO THERE'S NOT NOT THE SAME
LEVEL OF COMMITMENT.
WHAT IMPACT OR HAVE WE HAD A
CHANCE TO ASSESS THE IMPACT OF
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION AND
HELPING?
WITH THIS HAVE THEY BEEN VERY
HELPFUL HAVE THE IMPEDED
PROGRESS AND WHAT IT WHAT IS
HAPPENED IN TERMS OF THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM --
WE JUST WERE RECENTLY MADE AWARE
OF SOME OF THE FUNDING THAT --
IS BEING PROPOSED AND WE'RE
SAYING AS FAR AS OUR FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT IT IS --
THE SAME OR IN SOME CASES A
LITTLE HIGHER.
SO I THINK THAT THEIR COMMITMENT
DEALING AT THIS AS ON A NATIONAL
BASIS WITH SO MANY STATES BEING
HIT.
OTHER IS A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ADDITIONALLY THE ENACTMENT OF
WHAT ERIC VIEWED AS A LONG TERM
RECOVERY --
WE HAD. FOR A DISASTER.
RECOVERY FRAMEWORK --
THAT.
ALLOWS FOR THE MISSION TASKING A
FEDERAL ENTITY SUCH AS HUD COME
SIT WITH THE STATE AND THE
LOCALS TO TO ADDRESS COMPLEX
ISSUES.
OF THE FEDERAL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES --
PERSONNEL TO COME WITH OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH TO WORK OUT
HOSPITALS AND OUR OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES ISSUES.
SO I THINK THE COMMITMENT I
THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
GOVERNMENT I THINK THE
COMMITMENT IS THERE.
AN EIGHT BUT I THINK AS WITH
EVERYTHING THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT THE
DOCUMENTATION THE CERTIFICATION
THE QUALIFICATIONS ALL VERY --
VERY IMPORTANT AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT.
THERE.
ARE WE AT YOUR RECOMMENDATION --
YOUR COM THINGS SHOULD HAPPEN
SHOULD MOVE UP FROM THE LOCAL TO
THE STATE LEVEL IN TERMS OF
PLANNING --
DO WE HAVE THAT IN PLACE IN
TERMS OF A ONGOING RELATIONSHIP
WITH LOCALS TO BE ABLE TO
INCLUDE THEM IN THE PLANNING AND
THE RESOURCE DISTRIBUTE
DISTRIBUTION AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
DO YOU WANNA STARTED YOU WANT US
TO TALK ABOUT WILL GO AHEAD AND
START.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE SAM'S
PROCESS REALLY CLEARLY
IDENTIFIES FIVE LEVELS OF
RESPONSE IN COORDINATION.
AND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THERE IS
A LOT OF FREE STUFF OF DEMAND IN
ELEMENTS PUT ON US.
I ENDED BE KEY RIGHT NOW WHAT I
WAS REFERRING TO WAS THE CAL THE
CAL E. O. C. OR WEB EOC PLATFORM.
INFORMATION HOW IT SHARES FROM
THE FEEL ALL THE WAY UP THE
HELLO YES LEVEL.
WELL THE SYSTEM THAT'S AVAILABLE
STOPS FOR OUR JURISDICTIONS
STOPPED AT THE COUNTY.
THE LOCAL LEVEL DOESN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT SYSTEM.
IT UNTIL THE LAST YEAR SO WE ARE
WORKING ON DEVELOPING THE
SYSTEMS BUT IT'S AN OLDER SYSTEM
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE TO BEGIN
THAT THE CAPITAL SILICON VALLEY
WE'RE SEEING A LOT MORE
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN HELP.
MANAGE THE DATA THE DATA STREAM
THAT EXIST RIGHT NOW AND THERE
ARE THE OTHER OPTIONS THAT COULD
BE EFFECTIVE IN THE SHARING.
OF INFORMATION FROM THE FIELD
ALL THE WAY UP TO THE STATE.
YEAH THEM THAT'S A VERY GOOD
POINT HAPPY TO LOOK AT THAT WE
ARE ALWAYS LOOKING AT WAYS TO
IMPROVE THAT SYSTEM WE KNOW THAT
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS IS
CRITICAL SO WE HAVE A COUPLE
OTHER TOOLS BUT I KNOW THE
DIRECTOR MET WITH CEASE --
THE OTHER DAY AND I'M SURE THIS
MAY HAVE COME UP BUT HE IS VERY
OPEN TO LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
IMPROVE THE THE SYSTEM OR
SYSTEMS THAT WE USE.
DO YOU SEE ANY OF IT AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S IT THAT'S IT
CONCERNING THE GAP THAT'S THERE
DO YOU SEE ANY ADDITIONAL GAPS
THAT WE NEED TO BE AWARE OF THAT --
WOULD HAVE SOME IMPACT ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OF THE
OPERATIONS WELL ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS BROUGHT UP AS A
CREDENTIALING WHICH IS FABULOUS
IT'S SOMETHING WE AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE BEEN LOOKING
TOWARD.
AND HELPING UNDERSTAND HOW WE
CAN.
IMPLEMENT THAT WITHIN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SUPPORT CALLOW
YES IN THE CONCEPT OF MUTUAL AID.
WITHIN THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEMS OF
FIRE LAW THE VERY WELL
ESTABLISHED.
VERY SMOOTH.
THERE'S A SYSTEM CALLED AM OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM WHICH I DID NOT GET INTO
WITH THE TIME CONSTRAINT.
BUT THAT DOES NEED SUPPORT DOES
NEED NURTURING PRIMARILY BECAUSE
WHAT WE SEE THE LOCAL LEVEL IS
THIS THE LONG FIRE.
IS VERY WELL INTEGRATED AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND ACCEPTED AND
EMBRACED AND SUPPORTED WITH EVEN
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE YES
OFFICE.
THAT DOESN'T THAT DOESN'T
TRANSLATE RIGHT NOW TO THE ALMA
COORDINATION SYSTEM AND THEY
COULDN'T USE MORE NURTURING
THOSE ARE OTHER AREAS THAT WE
CAN THE CREDENTIALING.
CAN COME INTO THE CAMERA PROCESS
WE CAN SEE BECAUSE THE TIME
COMES WE'RE GONNA SEND HELP HELP
DOWN TO SAN DIEGO THERE TO SEND
HELP US.
WITH A CATASTROPHIC EVENT OCCURS.
AND REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
IF ALWAYS COMING I KNOW SHE CAN
DO THE JOB I DON'T KNOW HER
STAFF.
SO WHAT IS IT THEIR STAFF DOES
SO WE CAN ACCEPT THAT THAT
CAPABILITY AND OUR EOC AND VICE
VERSA.
THEY WOULD KNOW US AND OUR
RESOURCES AND OUR CAPABILITIES
SO IS A METHOD IN MEANS THAT WE
NEED TO EVALUATE AND LOOK AT
THESE MORE EFFECTIVELY.
OKAY -- IF
YOU HAVE TO ASSESS I MEAN WE'VE
HAD NUMBER THINGS HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST YEAR PROBABLY THINGS WE
NEVER EXPECTED BUT I GATHER FROM.
MUCH DISCUSSION IT BECOMES A NEW
NORMAL NOW --
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY HAS GONE WELL?
IN AN IN HOUSE IN THE OPERATION
AND WHAT WOULD YOU.
SAY ANY OF YOU THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO IMPROVE ON I KNOW WE GOT
THE LOCAL COORDINATION WHAT HAVE
YOU -- WELL.
YOU KNOW I I THINK WE LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS OF THE OF THE
PROPERTIES LOSS OF LIVES LOST
MORE IMPORTANT THAN PROPERTY AND
SO WE ASK OURSELVES THE QUESTION.
I WILL THAT WE DO.
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
FRIDAY AS WELL AS WE COULD --
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ENDING FOR THE
IN IN TERMS OF THIS YEAR AND
NEXT YEAR IS TO DO BETTER.
I THINK --
THE LIKE TO SAY THE COLLECTIVE
RESPONSE FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT THE AND
COMMUNITIES AND AMEND IMPACT I
THINK IS.
IS THAT A LEVEL WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE I THINK THAT STARTS WITH.
A WHAT WERE FORTUNATE TO HAVE
HEARING CALIFORNIA IS A
PARTNERSHIP AT AT AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL.
WITH CALLAWAY US.
CAL FIRE THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
THE FEMA REGIONAL OFFICE AND THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL THE
LEADERS OF THAT ORGANIZATION.
OUR MEETING REGULARLY.
DURING ALL PHASES OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ON ON PLANNING
FUNCTIONS THERE TOGETHER --
IN OUR UNIFIED COORDINATING
GROUP AND IN THE FIELD --
REPRESENTING THE ADMINISTRATION --
AND THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
PARTNERSHIP THERE THAT ALLOW
WHEN THE UNIFIED COORDINATING
GROUP IS STOOD UP AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER QUICKLY
ESTABLISH THOSE STATE PRIORITIES
AND JUST BE ABLE TO ADJUDICATE.
THOSE COMPLEX RESOURCE REQUESTS
THAT ARE COMING UP FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SO THAT PARTNERSHIP A
LEADERSHIP LEVEL HAS SERVED AS
WELL -- THE
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK JUST
BECAUSE OF THE SHEER NUMBER OF
EVENTS WE'VE HAD IN THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THOSE EVENTS
EACH OF EACH OF THAT.
THE LAST THREE EVENTS WE PAT
EACH ONE HAS GROWN INCREASINGLY
MORE COMPLEX THAN THE LAST --
WE ARE SEEING OUR STATE AGENCIES --
THAT HAVE CRITICAL ROLES TO PLAY
WHETHER IT'S PROCUREMENT WHETHER
IT'S MASCARA AND SHELTERING.
WE HAVE SEEN THOSE STATE
AGENCIES AND THEIR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMPONENT WITHIN THAT
AGENCY STEP UP THEIR GAME
SIGNIFICANTLY --
IN IN AREAS WHERE CALAWAY YES
USED TO HAVE TO TAKE A MORE
HANDS ON ROLE IN IN DIFFERENT --
FUNCTIONS DURING THE RESPONSE IN
SUPPORT OF COMMUNITIES WE GOT
STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE TAKING
THEIR ASSIGNMENT AND RUNNING
WITH IT VERY EFFECTIVELY --
OTHER AGENCIES ARE BEGINNING TO
COME ALONG TOO SO WE'RE SAYING
THAT THE THE TRAINING AND
CAPABILITY KEEP BUILDING
CAPACITY LEVEL OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES --
NOW I I THINK THE THE YOU KNOW
ALL THAT PRACTICE REALLY HAS
REFINED A LOT OF OUR OF OUR
SYSTEMS BUT IT'S ALSO.
YOU NOTE TO YOUR POINT MAKING
SURE THAT WERE SUPPORTING THE
LOCALS AND THEIR CAPABILITIES
AND I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED THE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM AND BEING
ABLE. TO TO OFFER THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS TO YOUR STAFF AND BEING
ABLE TO BE MORE --
INTEGRATED AND ASSURED SO WE CAN
SHARE THOSE RESOURCES FROM THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
I ALSO THINK THAT THE WIN AT
ERIC MENTIONED THE FIRST YOU
KNOW WE'VE SEEN THIS THAT FOR
THE ANIMAL THE ANIMAL ISSUES
DURING DISASTERS IS HUGE WHETHER
IT'S LIVESTOCK OR PERSONAL PETS.
IT'S A HUGE ISSUE IT'S GOTTEN A
LOT OF ATTENTION WE HAVE A LOT
OF RESOURCES ASSIGNED LOT OF
PARTNERSHIPS SO WE'RE SEEING THE
THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
FORMALIZATION OF THE HAVE LONG
TERM HOUSING.
STILL FOR EVEN FOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A BIG BIG DEAL BECAUSE
OF THE HOUSING ISSUES ALREADY SO
SO BEING ABLE TO HAVE PEOPLE
WITH THE EXPERIENCE KNOWING THE
NEEDS WORKING WITH THE LOCALS TO
SOLVE LOCAL PROBLEMS.
IS GOING TO HELP THE STATE AND
FEDERAL OF BECOME MORE EFFECTIVE
AND HAVE SOLUTIONS AND IDENTIFY
THOSE GAPS MORE QUICKLY AND
REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS SO THAT
YOU CAN RECOVER MORE QUICKLY
THAT'S THAT'S OUR DIRECTORS GOAL.
IS TO HELP THESE COMMUNITIES
RECOVER MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
MORE QUOTA EFFECTIVELY.
EVEN IN OUR JURISDICTION --
IN SAN JOSE AS WE'VE UPDATED OUR
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS PLAN.
WE'VE MADE --
URGENCY OPERATION PLANNED --
ENGAGING MORE SPECIFICALLY IN
CREATING A NEW SECTION IN OUR
SAM'S ORGANIZATION CALLED
RECOVERY --
AND WE HAVE DOESN'T DESIGNATED
STAFF WOULD COME AT THE START OF
THE EMERGENCY. TO START MANAGING
THAT ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST.
HOW ARE YOU GET REIMBURSED BUT
IN THE END?
IT'S THE CARE OF THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE IS THE CARE OF THOSE
NOT JUST TODAY AND THIS WEEK BUT
NOW THEIR HOME IS GONE WHAT WE
DO.
THE HOUSING CRUNCH THE THE
HOUSING THE INTEGRATION OF THOSE --
NON GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS.
IN UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY CAN
DO AS A SUPPORT MECHANISM.
AND BLENDING ALL THAT BECAUSE WE
KNOW WE AS A GOVERNMENT AGENCY
CAN'T DO IT ALL OURSELVES.
WE HAVE TO KNOW HOW TO BEST
BRING IN THESE OTHER DISH FOR
RESOURCES IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND MAKE A COMMUNITY BASED
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO KEEP THE
DON'T CHANGE UP.
AND LOOK AT SAM'S IN OUR OWN
ORGANIZATION AS A WAY OF SAYING
HEY WE HAVE TO OPEN UP SAM'S
IT'S IT'S TOO IT'S TOO DOGMATIC
IT IT'S OLD.
THIS TIME TO TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT THAT MEANS TO US.
THAT'S VERY ENCOURAGING I I I I
CAN REMEMBER AS OF BEING A PART
OF ONE OF THE SAN DIEGO FIRE
SOME YEARS AGO.
THAT THE LOOK LIKE THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO HAD THE AUTHORITY. TO OF
ORDER THE PLANE AND THAT WAS A
BIG ISSUE YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF
THEY HAD NOT HAD TO DO THAT
BEFORE AND SO WE WE HAVE THESE
PLANES THAT COULD DROP THE STUFF
EVERYWHERE.
AND THEY SPENT FOREVER TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHO TO WHERE WE NEED
TO THE GORE NOT WE WAS VERY LATE
IN THE GAME.
BUT THERE WAS A BIG ISSUE ABOUT
THAT AND MUCH FEAR AFTERWARDS SO
THAT WAS THEN AT THAT POINT.
A DISCUSSION THAT WE NEED TO
COORDINATE THIS IN ADVANCE OF
NOT WAIT TO THE FIRE TO FIGURE
OUT WHO HAS WHO CAN SIGN THE
PIECE OF PAPER RIGHT THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE SOME COORDINATION
AND IT WAS REALLY QUITE
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE THEY NEEDED
THE PLANES. TO TO TO FLY OVER
THIS HUGE PLANES THAT WERE RUN
BY I DON'T KNOW WITH US MARINES
WHAT IS BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WE COULD NOT GET
WHO HAD THE AUTHORITY TO SIGN.
IT AND SO YOU HIT ON SOMETHING
ELSE THAT IS WORKING A MUCH
BETTER AND THAT WAS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR UNIFIED
COORDINATING GROUP.
THAT INCLUDES BOTH THE MILITARY
AND THE NATIONAL GUARD SO THAT
THOSE WHEN THEY BECOME ISSUES
ARE MITIGATED IMMEDIATELY RUN
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT PEOPLE WITH
THE REACH BACK THEY CAN MAKE THE
PHONE CALLS.
AND GET IT RESOLVED.
BY TRAGEDY HAPPENED SAN DIEGO
INTO -- AS
PEOPLE LOOK AT THE FIRES ONLY
TRYING TO GET SOME RELIEF AND NO
ONE COULD FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THE ORDER THE PLANE.
AND A UNFORTUNATE DOCTOR
WHATEVER FIELD YOU YET YOU'LL BE
A ENCOURAGED TO LEARN THAT GUY
CAL FIRE LOCALLY HAS VERY UNIQUE
AGREEMENTS NOW WITHOUT YOUR NAVY
AND MARINE SO THAT THEY TRAIN
TOGETHER.
AND WE CAN CALL --
FOR DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
SUPPORT LOCALLY WHEN THERE IS A
BIG FIRE BUT I THINK.
ANOTHER THING THAT --
THAT HAPPENS DURING THOSE THE
AND THREE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
RELATES.
SOMEWHAT TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN MORE
RECENTLY AND YOU ASKED ABOUT
WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT COULD BE DONE --
WHAT CAN IMPROVE UPON IT'S BEEN
WELL DOCUMENTED THAT IN THE
FIRES IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THERE BEEN SIGNIFICANT?
UP PROBLEMS WITH WITH ALERT AND
WARNING AND SO THE STATE IS IS
STEPPING UP AND YOU KNOW GOING
TO BE SOON RELEASING SOME SOME
GUIDELINES BUT TRAINING TO GO
ALONG WITH THAT FOR LOCALS --
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT A THAT'S NOT
A TWO DAYS DOWN THE ROAD RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT WHEN THE FIRE
BREAKS OUT GETTING THE WORD TO
PEOPLE ON WHAT PROTECTIVE
ACTIONS THEY NEED TO TAKE
IMMEDIATELY.
AND SO I KNOW THAT SOMETHING THE
STATE'S WORKING ON BUT THE
ROLLING OUT THAT TRAINING AND
HAVING THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE THAT
SOFTWARE AND THOSE RESOURCES TO
ALERT THE PUBLIC IS CRITICAL.
WITH GREAT WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE NOW HAVE BUT WE'RE OPEN
FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT THERE
ARE THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE --
TO HAVE A MINUTE --
TO HAVE SOME COMMENTS CONCERNING
WHAT THEY'VE HEARD --
IF SO --
PLEASE COME TO THE MIKE THE
MICROPHONE IS THERE MAKE SURE
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME.
AND I WILL WE WILL GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES SINCE THIS DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE A WHOLE LOT OF SPEAKERS.
BUT WE WANT TO SEE.
WELCOME --
COMMITTEE SURE THE WEB OLD COME
A LONG WAYS --
TEN YEARS AGO SHOULD WE SAY --
I WATCHED FORWARD SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WHEN IT'S OFFICE WAS.
WONDERING HOW THEY RESPONDED FOR
DISABLED AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
THIS LAST YEAR RECOGNIZING IN
PART OF WHAT.
HAS TAKEN PLACE THAT INDEED THE
KNOW WHO ARE YOUR DISABILITY IN
YOUR COMMUNITY HOW YOU CONTACT
HIM ALSO WITH THE RESOURCES WENT
OVER AT CITY COLLEGE WERE
DEMONSTRATED FOR SOMEBODY BEING
BLIND TO OTHER THINGS.
THE NEEDS AND THE WAY YOU
SEPARATE AND THE HAVING PADS AND
IMPORTANT IN DEALING WITH NOT
JUST.
SOMEBODY BEING DISPLACED AS WELL
AS THE TRAUMA THE OTHER ISSUES.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK OF HIS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUR
ACCESSIBILITY IN ALL MATTERS.
ANNA ALSO SUGGEST THAT YOU
RETURN BACK TO CLEAR WATER IN
THAT FIRE BECAUSE I THINK THAT
GIVES YOU AN IDEA.
OF WHAT HAVE YOU REVIEWED TO
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE IN THE PAST.
TO NOW SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO
PLAN FIVE YEARS IN THE FUTURE OF
BJORN PRE POSITIONING RESOURCES.
I THINK YOU ALSO THROUGH ADDRESS
THE NEED OF MORE THE HOUSE SCENE
AND THE TEMPORARY SHELTER.
FOR NOT JUST DAYS BUT WEEKS SO
PLANS NEED TO COME IN THROUGH
THERE AND WORK ON THIS REGARD
NEEDS TO BE PART OF YOUR OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. TO KNOW
WHO WORKED WE'RE NGUYEN AND THE
CONTRACT I'D KNOW THE TERM
ORANGE KERN ST LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
HARD TO WORK WITHTHE FACT OF
THAT THEY DID NOT KNOW HOW TO
RESPOND TO SOMEBODY THAT WAS
BORING TO BE THING ELSE.
HIM THE TOOLS THAT YOU GIVEN
THEIR OF SIGN LANGUAGE IN THE
OTHER THINGS AND RECOGNIZING
STILL RIGHT NOW I THINK TO THIS
YEAR.
YOU STILL HAVING THE IN THAT A
NOTIFICATION OF SIGNED IN I
BELIEVE ORANGE CARE OR NOT
ORANGE COUNTY BUT SAN DIEGO CARE
ONLY YOU NOW HAVE A NEW WILDFIRE
TOOL.
THAT IS A CAMERA OR OTHER SYSTEM
THAT'S MUCH BETTER IN THE SYSTEM
I DO NOT KNOW WHETHER YOU KNOW
YOUR DRONE POTENTIAL AND OTHER.
ACCESSIBLE TOOLS TO IDENTIFY
OTHER ISSUES BUT I BRING THESE
ALL AS PUBLIC TO YOU IS IS THESE
OR INTERESTS CONCERN BUT I'M
HERE RIGHT NOW TO SPEAK.
TO THE FACT THAT HEY FROM
CONCERN AND PLEASE REMINDER AND
REMEMBER THAT.
I'M LIKE NOT EVERYBODY'S ABLE
BODIED TO MOVE AND TO WEAR GOAL.
AND WE HAD WHEN WE HAD WHEN I
PARTICIPATED IN THE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE IN LOS ANGELES.
OF REALIZING THE SITUATIONS THAT
NEED TO BE AND WHAT NEEDS TO AND
WE FORGOTTEN IT'S BEEN SO LONG
SINCE WE'VE HAD AN EARTHQUAKE
WATER THE TOOLS THAT ARE NEEDED
TO WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT NEED
TO SHOW.
THAT SIGN ON THE DOOR WHATEVER
ELSE TO GET TO THEIR IN THE
EFFORT TO GET THAT OUT.
THAT'S MY PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC.
OKAY VERY THOUGHTFUL IDEAS WE
NEED TO ALWAYS CONSIDER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
OF THANK YOU FOR COMING I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT --
WE WILL SOME OF YOU WILL SEE
AGAIN DOING THE BUDGET PORTION
BUT THERE WERE APPRECIATE THE
OVERVIEW AND THE INFORMATION TO
PRESENT AND WE APPRECIATE THE
TREMENDOUS JOB THAT YOU'VE DONE
WHEN I KNOW IT'S QUITE WITH THIS
YEAR WAS.
OVERWHELMING FOR ALL OF US TO TO
SEE THE THINGS THAT WERE
HAPPENING IT TO SO MANY AND YET
I THINK --
WILL BE BETTER PREPARED NEXT
TIME BUT NONE THE LESS YOU GUYS
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE TEN YEARS
AGO -- WITH
THE FIRES --
WE WERE MUCH BETTER PREPARED
THAN EVEN WITH THE GREATER
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS VERY --
AWARE OF THIS THAT THE CHALLENGE
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAD EVEN
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES BECAUSE
THEY WAS THERE NEIGHBORHOODS
THEIR FRIENDS THEIR FAMILIES.
AND I HAD TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
ON THE GROUND THE WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS WERE TAKEN
CARE OF AND CARED FOR SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE.
AND ALL THAT WORK WITH YOU AND
WE WILL OBVIOUSLY DO WHAT WE CAN
IN THE BUDGET TO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA IS BETTER PREPARED
ALWAYS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING WE APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH